Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is, therestishistory.com. Paradise is an all-new series set in a serene community inhabited by some of the world's most prominent individuals. But this tranquility explodes when a shocking murder occurs and a high-stakes investigation unfolds, starring Sterling K. Brown, James Marsden, and Julianne Nicholson. Paradise is now streaming only on Disney+. The enormity of his crimes was all the worse for the outrageous quality of the things he said. When his grandmother Antonia sought to give him some advice, he not only ignored
感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。若想获取每周独家播客、无广告收听、剧集抢先体验以及加入我们备受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。再次重申，网址是 therestishistory.com。《天堂》是一部全新剧集，故事发生在一个由世界上一些最显赫的人物居住的宁静社区中。但当一桩令人震惊的谋杀案发生、一场高风险的调查展开时，这份宁静瞬间被打破。该剧由斯特林·K·布朗、詹姆斯·麦斯登和朱丽安妮·尼克尔森主演。《天堂》现已独家上线 Disney+。他的罪行之巨大，由于其言论的无耻程度而变得愈发恶劣。当他的祖母安东尼娅试图给他一些忠告时，他不仅不理睬，
it but told her, Remember, I am allowed to do anything to anybody. When he exiled his sisters he warned them that he had swords as well as islands. When he had someone killed it was invariably by means of repeated delicate incisions so that as he notoriously liked to express it a man would die knowing that he was being put to the blade. When a case of mistaken identity led to the wrong man being executed, he declared that the person put to death had no less deserve to die. He liked to quote the proverbial line from the tragedy, let them hate provided they fear. Once at an elegant banquet, he suddenly out laughing, and when the consuls who were
反而对她说：“记住，我对任何人都可以为所欲为。”当他流放自己的姐妹们时，他警告她们，自己既有刀剑也有岛屿。当他命人处决某人时，无一例外都是通过反复精细的切割，正如他臭名昭著的习惯所表达的那样，一个人在临死前会清楚地知道自己正被刀刃割伤。当一起身份认错案导致无辜者被处决时，他宣称被处死的那个人死有余辜。他喜欢引用那句悲剧中的名言：“让他们恨吧，只要他们怕。”有一次，在一场优雅的宴会上，他突然放声大笑，而躺在附近斜椅上的执事官礼貌地询问他为何发笑时，他回答说：“哦，没什么，只是我只要轻轻点一下头，就能当场割断你们两个人的喉咙。”愤怒的是，当人群为与他最爱的人竞争的选手欢呼时，他大喊道：“要是罗马人民只有一个脖子就好了。”所以，这段话出自苏埃托尼乌斯为盖乌斯·凯撒·奥古斯都·日耳曼尼库斯所写的传记，许多听众可能更熟悉他的另一个名字——卡利古拉。汤姆，卡利古拉的名字，不仅在罗马历史上，而且在整个人类历史上，都是残暴、暴政、堕落和
reclining nearby politely inquired of him what had prompted such laughter, he answered, Why, only that with a single nod I could have either of your throats cut here and now. Angered, when a crowd cheered on contestants who were competing against his own favorites, he cried out, if only the Roman people had a single neck. So that is from the biography by Suetonius of Gaius Caesar Augustus Germanicus, who many listeners will better know as Caligula. Caligula's name, Tom, is one of the most notorious, not just in Roman history, but in all history, as a byword for sadism, tyranny, depravity, and
荒淫的代名词。而今天，我们要去探究其中究竟有多少是政治宣传，又有多少扎根于政治现实。因此，让我们把背景拉回到公元一世纪，卡利古拉是第三位皇帝，他在上一次我们提及的公元37年接替了提比略，而且他只统治了四年，对吧？没、错。然后他在28岁时被自己的卫兵谋杀了。在那段时期里，他没有取得任何伟大的军事胜利，也没有留下任何伟大的纪念碑。然而，正如你所说，
debauchery. And today, we're going to find out how much of this is propaganda and how much of it is rooted in political reality. So let's put into context from the first century AD, Caligula is the third emperor and he succeeds Tiberius who he did last time in the year 37 and he only rules for four years, right? That's right. And then he gets murdered by his own guards at the age of 28. And in that time, he doesn't win any great military victories. He's not responsible for any great monuments. And yet, as you say,
我的意思是，他一定能与尤利乌斯·凯撒、奥古斯都和尼禄并列。尼禄是有史以来最著名的罗马人之一。正如你所说，我的意思是，直到今天，他依然是残酷和性堕落的绝对代名词。因为他曾……那是什么来着，七十年代那种类似于软色情电影的东西，约翰·吉尔古德因为坐在浴缸里而让自己感到难堪。所以，是的，那种丑闻和堕落的氛围一直笼罩着他。而他生平中的一些轶事，我的意思是，大家都非常熟悉。据说他曾与自己的姐妹们发生性关系，把他的宫殿变成了一家妓院。他喜欢羞辱元老院元老。所以他会让他们在自己的战车旁奔跑，或者打扮成奴隶在晚餐时伺候他。
I mean, he has to be up there with Julius Caesar, Augustus, and Nero. Nero is one of the most famous Romans who's ever lived. And as you say, I mean, right up to the present day, complete byword for cruelty and also for sexual depravity. Because he was, what was it, that thing, that kind of sub porn film from the seventies where John Gillgit embarrassed himself by sitting in a bath. So yeah, so the kind of the flavour of scandal and depravity hangs over him. And some of the episodes from his life, I mean, you know, they're very well known. So he said to have slept with his sisters, turned his palace into a brothel. He likes to humiliate senators. So he'll have them kind of run by his chariot or serve him at dinner, kind of dressed up as slaves.
执事官忘记了他的生日，于是他解雇了他们。而且，可能也是最臭名昭著的故事——至少人们是这样理解的——是他让自己的马英卡图斯当上了执事官。实际上，苏埃托尼乌斯并不是这么说的，但我们会探讨这一点，并或许会梳理出这个故事的真正面目。而当你刚才在念那段话时，看 YouTube 的人肯定能看到，但当谈到割喉时，你转过身来，以一种威胁的眼神对我咧嘴一笑。我觉得其中带有极其微弱的、非常非常黑暗的黑色幽默成分。是指我，还是指卡利古拉，或者我们俩是一类人？
The consuls forget his birthday. And so he sacks them. And probably the most notorious story of all, And so he sacks them and probably the most notorious story of all, at least this is how it's understood, is that he made his horse in Catartus a consul. Actually that's not quite what Suetonius says, but we'll be looking at that and perhaps teasing out what that whole story might have been. And when you were reading that, people on the YouTube will have been able to see that, but when you talked about having throats cut, you turned and kind of grinned at me in a menacing way. And I think there is a slight element of kind of very, very dark comedy. About me or about Caligula or are we the same?
我是说你，是说苏埃托尼乌斯的记述，或许也是指卡利古拉本人，你不觉得吗？我的意思是，所有这些人，所有这三个人身上，都有一种“大吉尼奥尔”（Grand Guignol，恐怖血腥木偶戏）的特质。所以我认为苏埃托尼乌斯显然在揭示这一点，我觉得里面有一种独特的黑色幽默。实际上，当我翻译这段话时，我感受得非常非常真切，但很显然，卡利古拉身上也常常带有这种特质。因此，有一个特定的故事我非常喜欢，因为它实际上让我想起了查尔斯·狄更斯的小说《老古玩店》中那个心胸狭窄的侏儒奎尔普，
About you, about Suetonius' account and perhaps about Caligula himself, wouldn't you say? I mean there's a kind of quality of Grand Guignol. About all of those, all three of these people. So I think Suetonius is clearly revealing, I think there's a certain quality of black humour there. And actually when I was translating it, I felt it very, very kind of vividly, but it's clear that this is often Caligula's as well. So there was one, there was one particular account which I absolutely loved because it actually reminded me of the malevolent dwarf quilp in Charles Dickens' old curiosity shop and
那就是苏埃托尼乌斯对卡利古拉站在镜子前的描写。尽管他天生就有一张令人反感且丑陋的脸，但他却在镜子前勤奋地练习，让它变得更加丑陋，将其扭曲成各种可怕的表情。对，这就是我常做的事。看过 YouTube 的人应该都能看到。所以我想问题就在于，这很像我们昨天讨论提比略时的情景，这到底是怎么回事？我们该如何解释那些恐怖事件、堕落行径以及这些有时带有最黑暗喜剧色彩的怪诞轶事？它们真的发生过吗？
it's Stutonius' description of Caligula standing in front of a mirror. Though he had a naturally off-putting and hideous face, he worked diligently in front of a mirror to make it even more so, contorting it into all kinds of fearsome expressions. Yeah, that's what I do. People who've watched the YouTube will be able to see. So I guess the question is, pretty much as it was where we were talking about Tiberius yesterday, is what is going on? How do we explain all the horrors and the depravities and these kind of grotesque anecdotes that sometimes shade into the kind of the blackest kind of comedy. Did they actually happen?
巴伦：是的。奥康纳：如果它们真的发生了，那又该作何解释？卡利古拉疯了吗？他是个虐待狂吗？还是说，这有点像我们之前得出的结论——提比略一样，他也成为了假新闻的受害者？没错，完全正确。而且我们在研究卡利古拉时，异常依赖单一的史料来源，对吧？因为在研究提比略时我们有塔西陀，但在研究卡利古拉时我们没有塔西陀。关于卡利古拉，我们只有一些零碎的史料，或者像塞内卡或约瑟夫斯这样较小的史料来源，但苏埃托尼乌斯是唯一一个完整的记录者。
Will Barron Yeah. Jamie O'Connor If they did, what's the explanation? Was Caligula mad? Was he a sadist? Or is it a bit like we decided, I think, that Tiberius was, has he been the victim of fake news? Right, exactly. And we are, for Caligula, unusually dependent on one source, aren't we? Because we have Tacitus for Tiberius, but we don't have Tacitus for Caligula. There are fragmentary sources or smaller sources like Seneca or Josephus for Caligula, but Suetonius is the only full one.
这正是出自苏埃托尼乌斯的传记。我的意思是，从许多方面来看，它确实是整个文学史上最伟大的传记之一。我认为它真的是，是的。正是从苏埃托尼乌斯所著的卡利古拉传记中——可以说，甚至比他写的尼禄传记还要明显——我们得到了一个刻板印象中的罗马暴君形象：一个由于绝对权力而陷入彻底堕落的精神失常的罗马皇帝。我的意思是，这就是它的主题，不是吗？这是一个绝对权力导致腐败的典范。是的，我想这就是为什么苏埃托尼乌斯对卡利古拉的描绘具有如此深远的影响，
And it's from Suetonius' biography. I mean, it is actually in many ways one of the great biographies in all literature. I think it really is, yes. It is from Suetonius' biography of Caligula, really, arguably even more so than his biography of Nero, that we get the stereotypical image of the demented Roman emperor who has been driven into total depravity by absolute power. I mean, that's what this is, isn't it? It's a model of absolute power corrupting. Yeah, and I guess that that's why Pseudotonius' portrait of Caligula has been so influential,
因为这完全契合了“绝对权力导致绝对腐败”的观点。卡利古拉似乎成了这一说法的典型例证。因此，既然苏埃托尼乌斯对我们理解卡利古拉至关重要，并且在塑造他作为终极疯狂暴君的形象方面发挥了如此重要的作用，我认为我们有必要详细追溯苏埃托尼乌斯对他的生平和统治究竟有何言论。任何阅读过这本传记的人都会立即注意到一个惊人的事实，即苏埃托尼乌斯在讲述卡利古拉时，对他的血统、出身和家世的强调是多么不可思议。当然，原因最显眼不过了，那就是他登上了权力之巅。
because it's absolutely that idea that absolute power corrupts absolutely. Caligula seems to be the model illustration of that. So since Suetonius is so important to our understanding of Caligula and it's played such an important role in propagating the image of him as the kind of ultimate mad bad emperor, I think it's important to trace in some detail exactly what it is that Suetonius has to say about his life and reign. And one thing that will strike anyone who reads it immediately is how incredibly important in Suetonius's account of Caligula the emphasis on his bloodline is, on his pedigree, on his ancestry. And the reason for that, of course, most obviously, is that he comes to power.
他成为了皇帝，成为了元首（princeps）、罗马的第一人，凭借的正是他作为奥古斯都后代的身份——奥古斯都不仅是第一位皇帝，到此时更已成为神明。而卡利古拉主要是通过母系血统成为奥古斯都的后代的。因此，他的祖母是尤利娅，她不仅是奥古斯都唯一的孩子，自己也毁灭于一场性丑闻；而他的母亲是阿格里皮娜，她是奥古斯都最后在世的孙辈，我们在上一集里听说过她，她与提比略闹翻了。提比略将她囚禁在一个岛上，她绝食抗议并最终饥饿而死。但不仅是母系血统，不仅仅是来自母亲家族的血统增强了卡利古拉作为罗马血统最高贵之人的地位，
He becomes emperor, he becomes princeps, the first, most obviously, is that he comes to power. He becomes emperor, he becomes princeps, the first man in Rome, by virtue of his descent from Augustus, who is not just the first emperor, but by this point is a god. And Caligula is descended from Augustus very much through the female line. So his grandmother is Julia, who was Augustus' only child, and herself got destroyed in a sex scandal. And his mother is Agrippina, who was Augustus' last surviving grandchild, who we heard about in the previous episode, falls out with Tiberius. Tiberius imprisons her on an island. She goes on hunger strike and dies of starvation. But it's not just the female descent, it's not just the descent from his
还有他的父亲。这个人非常潇洒、非常英勇，以至于在他的一生以及随后的几十年里，他一直被纪念为罗马人民心目中的绝对宠儿。这个人享有日耳曼尼库斯（Germanicus）这个响亮的名字。苏埃托尼乌斯告诉我们，当提比略去世时，公众中爆发出了一种近乎狂喜的巨大热潮。苏埃托尼乌斯说，这不仅是因为提比略死了，更是因为日耳曼尼库斯的儿子掌权了。因此他写道：“整个民众阶层都将他的父亲日耳曼尼库斯的记忆铭记在心。”所以，日耳曼尼库斯是谁至关重要。而且，
mother's line that amplifies Caligulus' status as the best-bred man in Rome. There's also his father, and this is a guy who is so dashing, so heroic that throughout his life and in the decades that follow, he is commemorated as the absolute darling of the Roman people. And this is a guy who rejoices in the name of Germanicus. And Suetonius tells us that when Tiberius dies, there is this great kind of upsurge of public, almost ecstasy. And it's not Suetonius says just because Tiberius had died, but because the son of Germanicus has come to power. So he writes, the entire mass of the people classed the memory of his father, Germanicus, to their hearts. So it matters who Germanicus is. And
苏埃托尼乌斯意识到了这一点。在他的传记中，他极其详细地记述了日耳曼尼库斯的事迹。这几乎可以说是更广泛的卡利古拉传记中的一本“传记内传”。我的意思是，你甚至可以说他是“第十三位凯撒”。这是一个从未能成为皇帝的人，但苏埃托尼乌斯却深入讲述了他的故事。所以，给我们讲讲日耳曼尼库斯吧，因为基本上苏埃托尼乌斯认为日耳曼尼库斯是有史以来最好的人，做什么都极其出色，门门功课名列前茅，你知道的，是个杰出的演说家、杰出的学者，诸如此类。所以他描写日耳曼尼库斯的方式，就像如果你拥有一个假的红迪（Reddit）账号，会在“历史的其余部分”红迪板块上描写你自己一样。
Suetonius recognizes this. And in his biography, he gives us a very detailed account of Germanicus. It's almost a kind of biography within the broader biography of Caligula. I mean, you could always say he's the 13th Caesar. So he's a guy who never gets to become emperor, but Suetonius really goes into his story. So tell us a little bit about Germanicus, because basically Suetonius thinks that Germanicus is the best man who's ever lived, brilliant at everything, top of the class, you know, brilliant speaker, brilliant scholar, all of this kind of stuff. So he writes about Germanicus in the way that you, if you had a fake Reddit account, would write about yourself on the rest of history Reddit account.
我其实没有，为了以防万一说明一下，我没有假的红迪账号。不，你当然没有，但假设一下，仅仅假设一下。这就是苏埃托尼乌斯对日耳曼尼库斯的评价，正如你所说，他认为这个人绝顶聪明：“普遍的共识是，从未有人能像日耳曼尼库斯那样，将身体与精神的所有福祉集于一身。他既以美貌和勇气闻名，又在雄辩和学问上展现出非凡才华，无论是希腊语还是拉丁语皆精通无比；他以慷慨大度的精神而闻名，并且在赢得人们的忠诚和激发他们的喜爱方面取得了非凡的成功。”这些话我自己都想写下来。我告诉你，我觉得西奥——我们的制作人——有一个假的红迪账号，而且我觉得他会去红迪上把我们贬得一无是处。他大概会说接下来的这句话，因为苏埃托尼乌斯说日耳曼尼库斯的腿非常细。这是他唯一的缺点。
I actually don't, just to be clear, I don't have a fake Reddit account. No, of course you don't, but just suppose, just suppose. So this is what Suetonius has to say about Germanicus, who as you say, he thinks he's absolutely brilliant. It is the broad consensus that no one has ever combined all the blessings of body and spirit to the degree that Germanicus did. Conspicuous equally for his good looks and his courage, he was brilliant both as an orator and as a scholar, in Greek as in Latin, celebrated for his generosity of spirit and remarkably successful in his endeavors to secure people's devotion and inspire their affection. I would write that up myself. I tell you, I think Theo, our producer, has a fake Reddit
对。这正是西奥可能会对我们说的那类话。不过即使如此，日耳曼尼库斯还是把腿练粗了。这……这是他唯一的缺点。对。这正是西奥可能会对我们说的那类话。不过即使如此，日耳曼尼库斯还是把腿练粗了。这有点像我和我的教练。我把我的腿练粗了，
scant and I think he goes onto a Reddit and just slags us off. And he would probably say this next thing because, because Suetonius says of Germanicus that he has very spindly legs. That's his only drawback. Right. That's the kind of thing Theo might say of us. Although even then, Germanicus bulks them up. It's. That's his only drawback. Right. That's the kind of thing Thea might say of us. Although even then Germanicus bulks them up. It's a bit like me with my trainer. I've bulked my legs up.
简直不可思议。我把它们练得如此粗壮，以至于像绿巨人一样把裤子都撑破了。好吧。所以，日耳曼尼库斯也有着辉煌的家世，卡利古拉随后自然也继承了这一点。他是莉维娅的孙子，你知道的，莉维娅嫁给了奥古斯都，这使他成为提比略的侄子。
It's uncanny. I've bulked them up so much that I'm ripping my trousers apart like the incredible Hulk. Right. Okay. So Germanicus, he also has a brilliant pedigree, which of course Caligula then inherits. So he's the grandson of Livia, who is, you know, who marries Augustus, which makes him the nephew of
正如我们所说，他是绝对的金童。正因如此，奥古斯都才将他嫁（娶）给了自己的孙女阿格里皮娜。基本上，日耳曼尼库斯是被当作提比略的继承人来培养的。人们普遍认为，至少苏埃托尼乌斯是这么认为的，罗马历史学家们也大体如此：如果日耳曼尼库斯能够活下来，那么这一切都会非常完美，世界会变得美好，每个人都会幸福。因此，日耳曼尼库斯被刻意培训，接受了成为皇帝所需的所有艺术的教育。所以他被奥古斯都派去接替提比略担任日耳曼军团的指挥官。因为很明显，要成为
Tiberius. And as we said, he's the absolute golden boy. And so this is why Augustus marries him to his own granddaughter Agrippina. Basically, Germanicus is being groomed to succeed Tiberius. And the sense is, certainly with Suetonius, but more generally with Roman historians, that if Germanicus had managed to live, then this would have been brilliant, the world would have been great, everyone would have been happy. So Germanicus is kind of deliberately trained to be kind of schooled in all the arts required to be an emperor. So he is sent off by Augustus to succeed Tiberius as commander of the German legions. Because obviously to be a
凯撒，最重要的是你需要能够掌控军团的忠诚。他做得非常好，或者说看起来他做得非常好。因此，他的名字日耳曼尼库斯（意为“日耳曼的征服者”）是一个尊称。他获得这个称号是因为他率军跨越莱茵河，为瓦鲁斯麾下三个军团的惨遭屠杀向日耳曼部落复仇。他无休止地焚烧村庄，将日耳曼部落赶尽杀绝。而在罗马城内，人们认为这太棒了。所以他们称他为日耳曼尼库斯。尽管实际上，很明显提比略认为他有点像个爱出风头的花架子，并觉得这一切其实都是白费力气。但关键在于，这在罗马城内引起了极大的轰动，从而使人们更加爱戴他。而且他不仅深受罗马人民的喜爱，也深得驻扎在莱茵河畔的各军团的爱戴。
Caesar above all, you need to be able to command the loyalty of the legions. And he does very well, or at least it seems that he does. So his name Germanicus is a kind of honorific. He gets it because he is marching out across the Rhine to exact vengeance on the German tribes for their massacre of Varus' three legions. And he's endlessly burning villages and putting German tribes to the sword. And back in Rome, they think this is brilliant. So they call him Germanicus. Although actually, it's evident that Tiberius thinks he's a bit of a show pony and thinks it's actually all a bit of a wasted effort. But the point is, is that it creates a great stir back in Rome and so makes people love him even more. And he's popular not only with the Roman people, but with the legions
他极具个人魅力，是一位非常成功的将军，并且显然十分关爱军队。其中一个标志是，非常罕见且几乎违规的是，他把妻子阿格里皮娜和他们的孩子带在了身边。这其中就包括年幼的盖乌斯。此时的盖乌斯还只是个蹒跚学步的小幼儿。士兵们，你知道的，他是他们的心头小宝贝。因此他们为他做了一套军团士兵的行头，他就穿着盔甲和军靴在军营里蹒跚学步，而这种军靴在拉丁语里叫 Caligae。所以他们叫他卡利古拉（Caligula），意思是“小靴子”。这就是卡利古拉这个名字的由来。事实上，当奥古斯都去世时，莱茵河沿线爆发了哗变，因为士兵们不确定当前的
themselves who were stationed on the Rhine. He's very charismatic, he's a very successful general, he clearly cares for the legions. And one of the markers of that is that very unusually, and in fact almost illegally, he has his wife Agrippina and their children with him. And this includes the very young Gaius. Gaius is just a kind of little toddler at this point. And the soldiers, you know, he's their little pet. And so they, they make him a legionary outfit and he kind of walks around, toddles around the camp in his armor and his military boots, which in that in a Caligae. So they call it Caligula, which are little boots. So that's where the name Caligula comes from. And in fact, when Augustus dies, there are mutinies all along the line of the Rhine because they're unsure what the kind of
政治局势如何。他们基本上在威胁要拒绝承认提比略为皇帝。苏埃托尼乌斯说，唯一阻止他们发动全面叛乱的，就是卡利古拉的出现。日耳曼尼库斯说：“如果你们不冷静下来，我就要把卡利古拉带离军营，因为我信不过你们能照顾好他。”苏埃托尼乌斯说，这让士兵们感到羞愧，从而举止收敛了一些。你觉得这个故事是真的吗？嗯，塔西陀对这件事有更详细的记载，事情看起来似乎要稍微复杂一些。
political situation is. And they're threatening essentially to reject Tiberius as emperor. And the only thing, Suetonius says, that stops them from launching a full scale rebellion is the appearance of Caligula. And Germanicus says, if you don't calm down, I'm going to remove Caligula from the camp because I can't trust you to look after him. And this, Suetonius says, shames them into behaving a bit better. Do you think that story is true? Well, there's a much fuller account of this in Tacitus and it does seem trifle more complicated.
对。是的。我正想说，这听起来有点不太可能。如果你是真的铁了心要哗变，一个孩子的出现不太可能会让你……你知道的，他们可没有 Hallmark 贺卡撰写者的那种灵魂，对吧？他们对卡利古拉显然非常有温情。而这种将卡利古拉视作可爱小男孩的温情脉脉，在他成为皇帝后，绝对构成了其公众形象的一部分。所以，回到他的童年，他和他的家人——日耳曼尼库斯被提比略派往东方，
Right. Yeah. I was going to say, it seems a bit unlikely. Like if you're really serious about having a mutiny, the sight of a child is unlikely to, you know, they don't have the soul of Hallmark greetings card writers, do they? They're clearly very sentimental about him. And that vein of sentimentality about Caligula as this darling little boy is definitely a part of his public image when he becomes emperor. Right. So going back to his childhood, he and his family, so Germanicus is sent out to the East
去东方当大人物，不是吗？对，那是为了拓宽他的阅历。是的，而日耳曼尼库斯的一切也就是在那里开始走向失控的。同样，塔西陀对此有非常详细的记录，苏埃托尼乌斯的记载则简略得多，但基本情况是：日耳曼尼库斯作为提比略的全权代表被派往东方，但提比略也派去了他的一位贵族死党、一个名叫皮索（Piso）的人担任叙利亚总督，其主要目的就是
by Tiberius to be the big man in the East, isn't he? Right. So that's broadening his range of experiences. Yeah. And that's where it all goes wrong for Germanicus. Again, very detailed account of this in Tacitus. Suetonius gives a much more truncated account, but essentially what happens is Germanicus is sent out to the East as Tiberius' plenipotentiary, but Tiberius has also sent out one of his kind of aristocratic mates, a guy called Piso to be governor of Syria, basically to
监视日耳曼尼库斯。结果两人爆发了激烈的争吵。日耳曼尼库斯生病去世，并在临终前指控皮索对他下毒。当他们心目中的宠儿不仅死去、而且极有可能是被人谋害的消息传回罗马时，我的意思是，这产生了毁灭性的冲击，一股巨大的、翻滚的情感悲痛巨浪彻底席卷了罗马，这与戴安娜王妃事件相当类似。随后，阿格里皮娜带着日耳曼尼库斯的骨灰坛回到罗马，大肆渲染了这种悲痛，她走入罗马城，双手紧紧抱著骨灰坛，满脸泪痕，头发凌乱。罗马城的每个人都因悲痛和愤怒而彻底疯狂，因为他们将日耳曼尼库斯的死归咎于皮索。这种愤怒还牵连到了提比略，
keep an eye on Germanicus. And the two of them have a spectacular bust up. Germanicus falls ill, dies, and on his deathbed accuses Piso of having poisoned him. And the news that their favorite has not only died, but quite possibly been poisoned when it reaches Rome. I mean, it has a devastating impact and a great kind of rolling surge of sentimental grief completely takes Rome over, quite analogous to kind of the Princess Diana situation, which Agrippina then massively ramps up by returning to Rome, holding the urn with Germanicus ashes in it, kind of walking into Rome, clutching it with her, you know, tearstreet face and her disheveled hair. And everyone in Rome just goes completely berserk with grief and anger because they blame Piso for his death. And this anger also kind of involves Tiberius
因为他们认为提比略没有表现出足够的哀痛。所以这非常类似于人们对女王的态度。对，完全如此。因此，皮索最终选择了自杀，因为他知道自己基本上难逃一死；而提比略根本不是一个多愁善感的人，他对此抱有一种彻底的鄙视，就像爱丁堡公爵式的视角。所以难怪他和阿格里皮娜会有那样的关系，也难怪他们合不来。当然，不久之后，阿格里皮娜落得个惨死的下场，卡利古拉年纪最大的两个哥哥也相继丧命，大概都是奉了提比略的命令。因此，整个日耳曼尼库斯的传奇以极其悲惨的结局告终：卡利古拉年长的两个哥哥都被提比略除掉了。如今，他成了日耳曼尼库斯唯一的在世之子，也是奥古斯都在世的唯一曾孙，这使他成为提比略显而易见的继承人，然而这也反过来让他的处境变得极其脆弱和危险。尽管如此，在那时如果他是显而易见的继承人，元首（princeps）、皇帝这个职位，
because they think that Tiberius isn't showing adequate grief. So rather like with the queen. Yeah. Yeah, exactly. So Piso ends up committing suicide because he knows that basically he's doomed and Tiberius, who is not a sentimental man at all, views it with utter contempt in a kind of Duke of Edinburgh style perspective. And so it's no wonder that he and Agamemina don't get on having had that kind of relationship. And of course, in due course, Agrippina ends up dead and Caligula's two eldest brothers end up dead, presumably on Tiberius's orders. So the whole Germanicus story ends very, very sadly with Caligula's two eldest brothers having been eliminated by Tiberius. He is now the sole surviving son of Germanicus and the sole surviving great-grandson of Augustus, which makes him the obvious successor to Tiberius, which in turn makes his position very, very exposed and precarious. Although at that point, if he's the obvious successor, the post of princeps, of emperor,
显然已经退化成了一个君主制国家，不是吗？如果显而易见的继承人是这个家族中仅存的唯一一人，而唯一让他成为显而易见继承人的原因就是他的血统。嗯，我觉得情况稍微复杂一些，因为基本上当时的观点是，贵族继承祖先的地产、财富、头衔和荣耀是完全合法的。没有人对此有异议。因此，表面上的伪装是，奥古斯都的家族，也就是奥古斯都的家族只是和别的家族一样普通的家族，尽管很显然，它所带来的是对
has clearly degenerated into a monarchy, hasn't it? If the obvious successor is the only person left from the dynasty, and the only thing that makes him an obvious successor is his bloodline. Well, I think it's slightly more complicated than that, because essentially the idea is that it's perfectly legitimate for an aristocrat to succeed to the estate and the fortune and the titles and the glory of his ancestors. No one has a problem with that. And so the pretenses is that the August family, the family of Augustus are just a family like any other, even though obviously what it brings is the rule of the
世界的统治。所以这里面有一种失败的虚伪。你说的对，实际上它当然是个君主国，但没有人愿意承认这一点。奥古斯都曾想承认这一点。提比略不想承认这一点。元老院不想承认这一点。你知道的，所有人都把它藏在面纱之下，而这将在解释卡利古拉作为皇帝的政策时变得至关重要，也能解释为什么他会如此不受元老院的待见。但在那期间，他的处境非常危险。因此，提比略确实有他自己的孙子，那是一个叫格梅鲁斯（Gamelus）的小男孩。但卡利古拉年满18岁时，被提比略召集到了卡普里岛。而苏埃托尼乌斯不出所料地对卡利古拉在卡普里岛上的所作所为进行了严厉的痛斥。所以
world. So there is a kind of a failed hypocrisy about it. You are right, of course, effectively it is a monarchy, but nobody wants to admit that. Augustus had wanted to admit it. Tiberius doesn't want to admit it. The Senate don't want to admit it. You know, everyone keeps it under under a veil and this will become important in explaining Caligula's policy as emperor and why he becomes so unpopular with the Senate. But in the meanwhile, he is very exposed. So Tiberius does have a grandson of his own, who's a very little boy called Gamelas. But Caligula, he turns 18, he's summoned by Tiberius to Capri. And Suetonius is predictably very retuperative about what Caligula gets up to on Capri. So
他写道：“对于他而言，这座岛屿是一个充满危险的地方，充斥着各种试图诱骗或逼迫他对提比略满腹怨言的阴谋；但他不为所知，表现得好像他的家族从未遭受过灾难，其毁灭早已被他抛到了脑后；他坦然地将加诸于自身的冤屈一笔勾销，其伪装之真诚令人匪夷所思，而在他的祖父和朝臣面前，他又是如此奴颜婢膝、卑躬屈膝，以至于人们对他的评价可谓恰如其分：从来没有比他更好的奴隶，也从来没有比他更坏的主人。”
he writes, the island proved a treacherous place for him, rife with attempts either to trick or to pressure him into airing his grievances against Tiberius, but refusing to take the bait, he behaved as though nothing had happened to his family and their ruin had quite slipped his mind, dismissed the wrongs done him with a straight face so convincing that it beggared belief and was so ready to cringe and crawl before his grandfather and his courtiers that it hasared belief and was so ready to cringe and crawl before his grandfather and his courtiers that it has been said of him quite justifiably that never was there a better slave nor a worse master.
此外，还有一些关于……所以苏埃托尼乌斯显然把提比略在卡普里岛上的形象描绘得非常不堪，我们可以这么说。苏埃托尼乌斯还说，卡利古拉之所以能够讨好提比略，是因为他与提比略有着同样的残酷虐待狂倾向和变态胃口，不是吗？他喜欢看别人遭受酷刑，还喜欢穿女装，你知道的，诸如此类的事情。我猜你会说，这是围绕提比略构建的假新闻大厦的一部分。我们怎么知道呢？我的意思是，我们……你知道的，我们怎么能依赖这种说法？但同样地，神话的共鸣是如此压倒性，以至于它在自身层面上变得具有了历史意义。所以据说，提比略
And there's also this stuff about, so Soutenius has obviously painted a picture of Tiberius and Capri that is very damning, shall we say. And Soutenius also says that Caligula was able to suck up Tiberius because he shared his cruelty and deviant appetites, doesn't he? He likes watching people being tortured and he dresses up in drag and, you know, all of this kind of thing, which I'm guessing you will say is part of the sort of the fake news edifice that has been constructed around Tiberius. How do we know? I mean, we, you know, I mean, how can we rely on this? But again, the kind of the resonance of the myth is so overwhelming that it kind of becomes historically significant in its own right. So Tiberius
看着卡利古拉，鼓励他参与观看酷刑、色情歌舞秀或类似的东西。并且据说提比略曾评价卡利古拉说，他正在养育一个注定要成为罗马人民心头之患的毒蛇。我的意思是，这极其不可信。提比略认为自己是个深切的爱国者。他绝不会想要养育一条毒蛇，但这正是后来人们会持有的视角，因为当然了，苏埃托尼乌斯和其他历史学家都知道后来会发生什么，都知道卡利古拉会成为什么样的人。公元37年3月16日，提比略去世。不可避免地，正如苏埃托尼乌斯
watches Caligula, it is said, encourages him in, you know, joining in watching tortures or erotic floor shows or whatever. And is supposed to have said of Caligula that he was rearing someone fated to prove a viper to the Roman people. I mean, that's most improbable. Tiberius was, he felt that he was a deep patriot. He would not have wanted to rear a viper, but this is the perspective that will come to be put on it because of course, Suetonius and other historians know what is going to happen, know the kind of man that Caligula is going to be. So 16th of March, 37, Tiberius dies. Inevitably, there is what Suetonius
所描述的那样，流传起了一种貌似可信的传言，称卡利古拉是导致提比略之死的罪魁祸首。因此苏埃托尼乌斯说，卡利古拉对提比略下了毒，当毒药没有让他毙命时，他便用枕头将其闷死，而当这招也不管用时，他便动手勒死了他。这简直像是拉斯普京之死之类的桥段。完全如此，但据推测这一切都发生在空无一人的房间里，怎么可能有人知道呢？我的意思是，你根本无从知晓。于是，卡利古拉成为了元首。实际上，当时并没有其他人能够……你无从知晓。因此，卡利古拉成为了元首。实际上，并没有其他人能够，
describes as a plausible rumor that Caligula is responsible for it. So Suetonius says that Caligula poisons Tiberius, when he doesn't die he then smothers him with a pillow, and then when that doesn't work he strangles him. The death of Rasputin or something. Exactly, but presumably this is all taking place in an empty room, so how anyone would know? I mean, you don't know. And so Caligula then becomes Prince Epps. There is effectively, there isn't anyone else who can, you don't know. And so Caligula then becomes princeps. There is effectively, there isn't anyone else who can, you know, take his place. Gamalus is still, I think he's eight or nine, something, so no way that he can succeed. And so he becomes emperor.
你知道的，取代他的位置。格梅鲁斯当时大概才八九岁左右，因此他绝无可能继位。于是卡利古拉登基称帝。他登基时，对罗马公共生活、元老院如何运作、各行政长官所扮演的角色等等方面的经验都极其匮乏，而奥古斯都和提比略在成为皇帝之前，对所有这些都是经历过绝对系统的培养的。他也没有任何军事经验。他在元老院精英阶层中基本上没有任何朋友或盟友。所以你可能会想，既然如此，这个年轻得过分的小伙子怎么可能成功接管世界的统治呢？答案是，卡利古拉显然拥有极其冷酷无情、甚至可以说是冷血的政治智慧。他之所以懒得去弄清楚元老院的行为方式或执事官的职责之类的事情，是因为他
And he does so as someone with very, very little experience of public life in Rome, of how the Senate functions, of the role played by the magistracies, all of these kinds of things, which of course both Augustus and Tiberius had absolutely been raised in before they became emperor. He also has no military experience. He doesn't really have any friends or allies among the senatorial elite. And so you may wonder, well, that being so, how could this very young man possibly succeed to the rule of the world? And the answer is that Caligula clearly has a very unsentimental and you might say pitiless intelligence. And the reason that he hasn't bothered working out how the Senate behave or the role of the consuls or anything is that he's
已经意识到，这些东西实际上已经不再重要了，在国家权力结构中存在着更为核心的权力中心，其中最显眼的就是这支被称为“近卫军”（praetorians）的卫队。因此，praetorium 指的是军事总部，而近卫军则是传统上负责保护军事指挥官的卫队。奥古斯都作为帝国各地各个军团的最高统帅，必须拥有他自己的近卫队。所以他拥有自己的近卫军，提比略也同样拥有。他在罗马城墙内为近卫军建立了一个巨大的军事基地。而卡利古拉已经意识到，这才是真正重要的事情。
recognised that that effectively doesn't really matter anymore, that there are much more significant centres of power in the state, of which the most obvious is this group of guards called the praetorians. So a praetorium is the military headquarters and the praetorian guards are the guards that traditionally look after someone who is in military command. And Augustus in his role as supreme commander of the various legions across the empire, he has to have his own praetorian. And so he has his praetorian guards and Tiberius has them as well. And he has built the praetorians, a great military base and the walls of Rome. And Caligula has recognized that this is what matters.
因此，他确保拉拢了他们，尤其是近卫军的统帅——一个名叫马克罗（Macro）的人。当然，他的血管里也流淌着被神化的奥古斯都的血液。所以他，你知道的，身上带有一丝那样的光环。正如我们所说，民众因为他是日耳曼尼库斯的儿子而对崇拜他。因此，当卡利古拉护送提比略的遗体前往罗马时，沿途受到了狂热人群的围观和欢呼。再次引用苏埃托尼乌斯的话，欣喜若狂的祝福人群称他为“他们的明灯”、“他们的雏鸟”、“他们的心肝宝贝”、“他们的乖宝宝”。元老院的成员们，你知道的，他们看着这一幕，心里想着：哦天哪，我的意思是，
And so he's made sure to square them, and particularly the head of the praetorians, guy called Macro. He also, of course, has the blood of the deified Augustus in his veins. So he, you know, there's a touch of the there. And the people, as we've said, adore him because he is the son of Germanicus. And so when Caligula accompanies Tiberius's body to Rome, he is mobbed and cheered the whole way. And again, to quote Suetonius, ecstatic crowds of well-wishers called him their shining light, their chick, their poppet, their baby boy. The senators, you know, they're watching this and thinking, oh lordy, I mean,
对此我们无能为力。于是，他们投票将奥古斯都花了一生时间才积聚起来的所有权力，全部授予了这位24岁的卡利古拉。显然，他们对此并不是特别高兴，只能咬牙切齿地忍着。是的，毫无办法，你知道的，他们能怎么办？他们只能接受现实。而且从一开始，卡利古拉就证明了自己是一个迎合民众、讨好底层观众的大师，不是吗？他让我想起了一个人，车臣的统治者拉姆赞·卡德罗夫（Ramzan Kadyrov），他也是继承了……你知道的，他继承了他父亲的权力，虽然这并非真正的君主制，但他总是喜欢摔跤、和好莱坞电影明星混在一起之类的事情。而卡利古拉正是那种类型，不是吗？他喜欢轰动性的、戏剧化的、能博得底层民众欢呼的手势。是的，他确实喜欢。而且，我当时想到的也许还有查尔斯·斯宾塞（Charles Spencer）。
there's nothing we can do about this. And so they vote the 24 year old Caligula, all the powers that it had taken Augustus a lifetime to accumulate. And obviously they're not particularly happy about that. They're sticking their crawl. Yeah, there's nothing, you know, what can they do? They've got to suck it up. And right from the start, Caligula proves himself a master, doesn't he, of playing to the people, to the gallery. He reminds me a bit of a guy, the guy who's the ruler of Chechnya, who was called Ramzan Kadyrov, who also succeeded,
好吧，这三个人平时可不怎么会被相提并论。不，但就像查尔斯·斯宾塞在他姐姐葬礼上发表的那篇演讲一样，那篇演讲确实将那种戏剧化和强烈的情感渲染到了极致。卡利古拉意识到，他作为日耳曼尼库斯和阿格里皮娜的儿子的身份，是他神话、他的形象中至关重要的一部分。因此，他一到达罗马并成为皇帝，一旦做完这些，他就立刻乘船前往他的母亲和哥哥去世的监狱岛屿，收集了他们的骨灰，然后返回罗马，乘船逆台伯河而上。他乘坐着这艘大船，船头迎风高高飘扬着他的旗帜，靠岸后，他便模仿他母亲当年捧着日耳曼尼库斯骨灰的样子，
you know, he succeeded his father, it's not really a monarchy, but he's always like wrestling bears and trying to hang out with Hollywood film stars and stuff. And Kaligula is very much of that ilk, isn't he? He likes a sensational melodramatic, cryopleasing gesture. Yeah, he does. And again, I was thinking perhaps of Charles Spencer. Yeah, there's three people who aren't often bracketed together. No, but in that speech that Charles Spencer gave at his sister's funeral, which kind of really ratcheted up the sense of kind of melodrama and emotional intensity. Caligula, he recognises that his status as the son of Germanicus and of Agrippina is an important part of his mythos of his
手里捧着母亲和哥哥们的骨灰，步行前往战神广场上奥古斯都宏伟的陵墓，将骨灰安葬在那里。苏埃托尼乌斯特别指出，他选择在正午、也就是全城最繁忙的时候这样做。因为他想让所有人都看到他。然后他
image. So the moment he's arrived in Rome and become emperor, as soon as he'd done that, then he's off on a ship off to the prison islands where his mother and his elder brother had died and he scoops up their ashes and he returns to Rome and he sails up the Tiber. He's on this great ship with his standard fluttering proudly in the prow and he lands and he then walks rather as his mother had walked with the ashes of Germanicus. He walks with the ashes of his mother and his brothers to the great mausoleum of Augustus on the campus martius where he lays them. And he does this, Suetonius specifies, at midday when the city was at its busiest. So he wants everyone to see him. And he then
刻意发布公告，基本上宣告：提比略严酷的时代已经结束，黄金时代已经到来，我是慷慨与仁慈的光辉典范。因此，他向所有在提比略在世时面临指控的人大赦天下；他恢复了被提比略废除的民众选举，即行政长官的选举。这在民众中反响极好。并且他庄严承诺，他绝不做任何让任何人憎恨他的事，也绝不听信告密者的话。这就是他的政治宣言。与提比略形成鲜明对比的是——这是一个非常尖锐的对比——他举办了各种各样的精彩大秀。我们在上一集里谈到过，
goes out of his way to kind of issue proclamations, essentially saying, you know, the grim age of Tiberius is over, it's a golden age has come, I am a kind of shining model of munificence and benignity. So he issues amnesties to all those who are facing trial on charges that had been brought against them while Tiberius was living. He revives the popular elections, so the elections for magistracies that Tiberius had abolished. And this goes down well with the people. And he gives a solemn promise that he will never do anything to make anyone hate him and will never give ear to informers. So this is his manifesto. Also in contrast to Tiberius, very pointed contrast to Tiberius, he lays on all kinds of spectacular shows. So we talked in the previous episode how
提比略鄙视大众所喜爱的东西。他根本没有时间去看角斗士表演。提比略心目中的美好时光是来一场类似酒吧知识问答（pub quiz）的活动。他喜欢出一些关于文学之类的智力题。这才是他心目中的美好时光。而卡利古拉可不这样。有角斗士表演、有猛兽秀、有战车赛，而卡利古拉尤其喜欢战车赛。他与
Tiberius despises the things that the mass of the people like. He has no time for gladiatorial shows. Tiberius' idea of a good time is to have a kind of pub quiz. He likes setting quizzes on literary matters and things like that. That's his idea of a good time. Not Caligula's. So there are gladiators, there are beast shows, there are chariot races, and Caligula particularly likes chariot races. He identifies very strongly with
其中某一个车队紧密联系在一起，非常坚定地支持他们，并且他酷爱散财。他会玩一种游戏，把一些代币或筹码抛向人群，根据你捡到的代币，你会得到相应的奖品。这可能是一头……我不知道，只是一头小猪什么的，也可能是一栋别墅。所以，哇哦。他喜欢坐在那里看着人们争相抢夺、互相肘击，
one of the particular teams, kind of backs them very strongly and he loves scattering largesse. So he will do this thing where there are kind of tokens and he'll throw these tokens out into the crowd and depending on which token you pick up, you will get something. So it might be, I don't know, just a barn or something, or it might be a villa. So wow. And he likes to sit there and watch people scrabbling and elbowing, you know, each other out of the way to grab them. And so Tony says he was tireless in promoting shows of every description on stages across Rome. And sometimes even did so by night making the whole city blaze with light.
好把东西抢到手。苏埃托尼乌斯说，他在罗马各地的剧院里不知疲倦地推动各种规模的表演，有时甚至通宵达旦，让整个城市灯火通明。我知道我们会在下半集详细讨论这个，但我的意思是，简而言之，他显然是一个天生的民粹主义者，不是吗？是的，正如罗马人所称的那样，是一个“平民派”（popularis）。显然，问题在于，元老院里有许多人并不是天生的民粹主义者，民粹主义对他们而言简直是十恶不赦。他们看着这个家伙——多大来着，他几岁？24岁。24岁，从未担任过高级
So I know we'll get onto this in the second half, but I mean very quickly, he's obviously a natural populist, isn't he? Yes, a popularist, as the Romans would call it. Now obviously the issue there is then there are lots of people in the Senate who are not natural populists for whom populism is anathema. And they're looking at this bloke who's what in his, how old is he? 24. 24, has never held a senior 24, has never held a senior
指挥职务，从未担任过高级官职——他们肯定在想：这太疯狂了。我的意思是，为什么这个家伙在统治罗马？他完全无法胜任，而且他与我们所坚守的一切都背道而驰，我们坚守的是传统、正直、严肃，所有这些东西。是的。而整个罗马传统——在整个共和国时期都有所体现——就是年纪大才是王道。这就是为什么共和时期的肖像半身胸像总是展现出下垂的双下巴、眼角纹之类的特征。人们有一种本能的看法，即年轻人天生就是暴力和好斗的，还没有学会控制自己的欲望。而卡利古拉似乎决心要将这一点淋漓尽致地展现出来。因此，他们对他的种种开玩笑、大声嗤笑感到愤恨，如果你正在元老院发表慷慨激昂的演讲，这显然极其让人分心。他们讨厌他整天把战车赛挂在嘴边。卡利古拉有一种……我的意思是，这基本上有点像开着一辆极速跑车。他有数量惊人的战车和骏马带着他在罗马街头飞驰。他出风头的风范让他们感到非常非常被冒犯。当然，你知道的，所有这些角斗士表演之类的东西，我的意思是，这花销巨大。而提比略一直以来都非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常节俭甚至吝啬。所以国库其实
command, has never held a senior office and they must be thinking, this is mad. I mean, why is this bloke ruling Rome? He's completely out of his depth, but also he's against everything that we stand for, which is tradition, integrity, seriousness, all of these things. Yeah. And the Roman tradition, which had been manifested throughout the Republic, is that it's brilliant to be old. So that's why Republican portrait busts, they're always showing themselves with kind of sagging jowls and crow's feet and everything like that. And there's an instinctive sense that young people are just kind of naturally violent and aggressive and haven't learnt to temper their appetites. And Caligula seems set on kind of illustrating this. So they, they resent the way that he kind of makes
命令，从未担任过高级职务，他们一定在想，这太疯狂了。我的意思是，为什么这个家伙在统治罗马？他完全无法胜任，而且他也违背了我们所代表的一切，也就是传统、正直、严肃，所有这些。是的。罗马的传统在整个共和国时期都有所体现，那就是老就是好。所以这就是为什么共和国时期的肖像半身像总是展示出他们下垂的双下巴和鱼尾纹之类的特征。人们有一种本能的观念，认为年轻人只是天生好斗、具有侵略性，还没有学会克制自己的欲望。而卡利古拉似乎决心要证明这一点。所以他们，他们怨恨他那种
jokes and he sniggers loudly, which is obviously very off putting if you're giving a grand oration in the Senate. They hate his, you know, the way that he's always going on about chariot racing. Caligula has a kind of thing. I mean, it's basically kind of a bit like driving a very fast sports car. He has an insane number of horses that draw him on his chariot through the streets of Rome. He's cutting a dash in a way that they find very, very offensive. And of course, you know, all these gladiator shows and stuff, I mean, it's expensive. Tiberius had been very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, veryias have been very, very abstemious and mean. So the treasury is quite
开玩笑、大声窃笑的方式，如果你在元老院发表宏伟的演说，这显然非常令人反感。他们讨厌他，你知道的，他总是喋喋不休地谈论赛车。卡利古拉有一种特殊的癖好。我的意思是，这基本上有点像驾驶一辆非常快的跑车。他有数量惊人的马匹拉着他的战车穿过罗马街头。他以一种他们觉得非常非常冒犯的方式出风头。当然，你知道，所有这些角斗士表演之类的东西，我的意思是，这很昂贵。提比略一直非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常非常的有非常高兴，可以当我们的一个新朋友。它其实也展示了我们对他的看法，也展现了他在罗马元老院那种格格不入的境遇。所以我想知道，你觉得元老院里的人，他们对卡利古拉的这种行为是怎么看的？
full, but Caligula is kind of burning through it at an absolute rate of knots, but they haven't really got any choice except to hold their breath and cross their fingers and trust that everything will be okay. And it is a good sign for them that along with all his other kind of measures designed to make him look good, he said that there aren't going to be any more treason trials, we're not going to have them. So you can rely on that. So the first eight months of his rule, you know, there were worrying signs, but there hasn't been kind of any major, major confrontation between Caligula and the Senate. And then in October 37, so as I say, eight months after coming to power, Caligula falls ill. And this is a very dangerous moment because this isn't a formal monarchy. There aren't
很充裕，不过卡igula正在以惊人的速度挥霍它，不过除了屏住呼吸、交叉手指并祈祷一切都会好起来之外，他们其实别无选择。对他们来说，一个好兆头是，除了所有其他旨在让他看起来不错的措施外，他说不会再有叛国审判了，我们不会再搞这些了。所以你可以指望这一点。所以在他的统治的前八个月，你知道的，有一些令人担忧的迹象，但卡igula和元老院之间并没有发生任何重大、重大的冲突。然后在37年10月，正如我所说，即掌权八个月后，卡igula病倒了。这是一个非常危险的时刻，因为这不是一个正式的君主制。并没有
set rules establishing how when one princeps dies, a new princeps comes to power. And so the moment Caligula falls ill, it looks like he's going to die. All the heavyweights in his administration are scrabbling around trying to work out who his successor will be. And the obvious successor is this young lad, Gamelis, kind of 13 or 14 by this point, Tiberius' only grandson. So they are going off and kind of paying court to him and preparing to elevate him to the throne. And meanwhile, there is this absolute toady, this lickspittle, a guy called Atenius who swears a solemn oath that if only the gods will restore Caligula to health, then he will go into the arena and fight publicly as a
建立了一套规则，规定当一个元首（princeps）去世时，新元首是如何上台的。因此，当卡igula病倒的瞬间，看起来他快要死了。他政府里所有的大人物都在四处奔忙，试图弄清楚谁会是他的继承人。而显而易见的继承人就是这个叫加梅利斯的年轻小伙子，当时大约13或14岁，是提比略唯一的孙子。所以他们都跑去向他朝贡，并准备将他推上王位。与此同时，有一个绝对的马屁精、奴才，一个叫阿特尼乌斯（Atenius）的家伙，他发下庄严的誓言，只要神明能让卡igula恢复健康，他就会亲自走进竞技场，公开进行角斗士
gladiator. And obviously he doesn't expect that this would happen. It would be unthinkable for someone of his rank and age to go into the arena and fight a trained killer. But you know, he's basically hedging his bets. If Caligula survives then it'll be great. You know, he'll approve of his loyalty and if he doesn't, then no one will remember it. Caligula does recover, I think against the odds. And he rises from his sickbed and he's informed what Artanis has done and also more significantly what the captain of the Praetorians and you know, his leading senatorial backers, what they've been up to going around and paying court to Gamelas and he moves with absolute lethal dispatch. So first off, he sends two soldiers to Gamelas who sit the boy down and take out their knives and show Gamelas the best
战斗。显然他并没有指望这会发生。对于他这种身份和年龄的人来说，走进竞技场与一个受过训练的杀手搏斗是不可想象的。但你知道的，他基本上是在给自己留后路。如果卡igula活下来，那太好了。你知道的，他会赞赏他的忠诚；如果他没活下来，那么也没人会记住这事。卡igula确实康复了，我认为这超出了预期。他从病榻上站起来，得知了阿特尼乌斯做了什么，更重要的是，近卫军指挥官和他的主要元老院支持者们一直在到处向加梅利斯朝贡，他以极其致命的速度采取了行动。首先，他派了两名士兵去找加梅利斯，让这名男孩坐下，掏出他们的刀，向加梅利斯展示了最好的
way to kill himself and then stand there and watch while Gamalus kills himself. And that's the end of him. Gamalus' would-be patrons, including the prefect of the Praetorians, are likewise ordered to commit suicide, which they do. And Aetanius, this guy who has vowed that he will fight a gladiator, if only Caligula recovers. Well, so this is what Suetonius says happened. Caligula takes him at his word and he forces this poor guy. I mean, he's not at all the kind of person who is fitted either by background or I think by physique to face up to a trained gladiator out into the arena. Atenius is killed very briskly, he's dragged off with a hook across the sand, his body is dumped and Caligula's sense of humor has this kind of bloody punchline.
自杀方法，然后站在那里看着加梅利斯自杀。这就是他的结局。加梅利斯的准支持者们，包括近卫军长官，同样被命令自杀，他们也照做了。而阿特尼乌斯，这个曾发誓只要卡igula康复就去当角斗士的家伙，嗯，苏维托尼乌斯就是这么记录的。卡igula当真了，他强迫这个可怜的家伙——我的意思是，无论是从背景还是我认为从体格来看，他根本就不是那种适合去竞技场面对受过训练的角斗士的人。阿特尼乌斯非常利落地被杀死了，他被用一个钩子拖过沙子，尸体被随意抛弃，而卡igula的幽默感有着这种血腥的笑点。
And people in the arena undoubtedly found it funny. I mean, it's exactly the kind of joke that would have appealed to a crowd of people gathered to watch blood sports. But it also sends a pretty chilling message to the Roman elites that, you know, there's no more Mr. Nice guy. And there's the definite sense that Caligula has been biding his time. And now that he has the evidence that some of the Senate have been conspiring against him as he sees it by kind of going after Gamalus, he is ready for the kill. And Suetonius, he has this kind of wonderful pivot in his biography. I think the single greatest line ever written in any biography ever where he writes, enough of the princeps, what remains to be described is the monster.
竞技场里的人毫无疑问觉得这很好笑。我的意思是，这正是那种会吸引聚集在一起观看血腥运动的乌合之众的笑话。但这也向罗马精英阶层传递了一个相当冰冷的信息，那就是，老好人已经不复存在了。而且有一种明确的感觉，卡igula一直在隐忍等待。现在他有了证据，证明一些元老院成员一直在密谋反对他——在他看来是通过拉拢加梅利斯——他已经准备好痛下杀手了。而苏维托尼乌斯，在他的传记中有一个非常精彩的转折。我认为这是任何传记中写过的最伟大的一行，他写道：关于元首的叙述到此为止，接下来要描述的是怪物的面目。
Crikey. So the monster is coming and we will be back after the break. TV. The West Side Ripper is back. If you're not killing these people, then who is? That's what I want to know. Starring Kayleigh Cuoco and Chris Messina. The only investigating I'm doing these days is who shit their pants. Killer messaged you yesterday? This is so dangerous. I got to get out of this. Based on a true story. New season Mondays at 9 Eastern and Pacific.
天哪。所以怪物要来了，我们休息一下马上回来。电视节目。西区开膛手回来了。如果不是你在杀这些人，那是谁？这就是我想知道的。由凯莉·库柯和克里斯·墨西拿主演。我最近唯一在调查的事情是谁拉裤子里了。杀手昨天给你发消息了？这太危险了。我得离开这里。改编自真实故事。新季度每周一美东和太平洋时间9点播出。
Only on W. Stream on Stack TV. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. Enough of the print caps, what remains to be described is the monster. So Tom, you described this as your favourite line in the history of biography and we are moving now. Caligula has been clearly very shocked by the speed with which people move to associate themselves with a potential successor when he felt ill. And politically that makes sense that he would be insecure and he would wish to, he's looking for enemies.
只在W播出。在Stack TV上观看。欢迎回到《历史就是这样》。关于元首的叙述到此为止，接下来要描述的是怪物。所以汤姆，你把这描述为你所读过的传记历史中最喜欢的一句话，我们现在继续。卡igula显然对人们在他生病时迅速与潜在继承人拉关系的速度感到非常震惊，从政治上看，他会感到没有安全感并希望寻找敌人，这在情理之中。
But from this point onwards in the biography, Suetonius is really going beyond that and he is basically saying Caligula is a died in the world, inveterate, debauched, depraved monster. And talk us through some of the examples Tom that he gives of this kind of behaviour. Right, so there are various examples that Suetonius gives of the character of a monster that he says Caligula has. Perhaps the most shocking is that Caligula demands worship as a god. So Augustus, you know Caligula demands worship as a god. So Augustus had been, you know, he's worshipped as a god, but not in his lifetime. Augustus had really stamped down against any thought of that. But Caligula, Suetonius says he's
但从传记的这一点开始，苏维托尼乌斯真正超越了这一点，他基本上是在说卡igula是一个彻头彻尾的、根深蒂固的、荒淫无度的、堕落的怪物。汤姆，给我们讲讲这种行为的一些例子吧。好的，苏维托尼乌斯举出了各种例子来说明卡igula具备的怪物性格。也许最令人震惊的是，卡igula要求人们像神一样崇拜他。所以奥古斯都，你知道卡igula要求人们像神一样崇拜他。所以奥古斯都曾被，你知道的，他被当成神一样崇拜，但不是在他生动之年。奥古斯都曾极力压制任何这种想法。但卡igula，苏维托尼乌斯说他是
all in. So Suetonius reports that Caligula orders some of the most famous statues of the gods from Greece, brought to Rome. He replaces the heads of the gods with his own head. Senators compete to serve him as priests. They offer up all kinds of sacrifices to him. So, Soutanius specifies flamingos, peacocks, black grouse, two varieties of guinea hen, pheasants. There are times when Caligula will dress up as various gods. So, sometimes as Jupiter, even shockingly as Venus. And there are other times where he will claim to be talking to Jupiter. So this is all clear evidence of either monstrousness or insanity or both. So Suetonius says that he essentially goes out of his way to humiliate the elites in every way he can. And obviously the most humiliating
全力以赴的。所以苏维托尼乌斯报道说，卡igula下令将希腊一些最著名的神像运到罗马。他用自己的头像替换了神像的头部。元老们争相充当他的祭司。他们向他献上各种祭品。所以，苏维托尼乌斯具体提到了火烈鸟、孔雀、黑琴鸡、两种珍珠鸡、野鸡。有时卡igula会打扮成各种神明。有时打扮成朱庇特，甚至令人震惊地打扮成维纳斯。还有的时候，他会声称自己正在跟朱庇特对话。所以这都是他是怪物、精神失常或两者兼有的明证。因此苏维托尼乌斯说，他基本上是不遗余力地从方方面面羞辱精英阶层。显然，最羞辱人的
thing that you can do to a Senator is to treat him as a slave. So Suetonius specifies that he would brand senators equestrians who had offended him with branding irons, after which, Suetonius writes, he would condemn them either to the mines or to the building of roads or to be thrown to wild beasts or to be shut up in cages on all fours like animals or to be sawn in half. So none of that's fun. He takes his vendetta against the elites even to the extent of toppling their ancestors. So statues of famous men from Rome's past, Pseudotonia says are toppled and smashed to pieces. And he also says that members of the aristocracy with famous names, they're told to get rid of these names. So the Pompeys, for instance, Pompey
事情，莫过于把元老当作奴隶对待。因此苏维托尼乌斯具体指出，他会用烙铁在冒犯过他的元老和骑士身上打上烙印，此后，苏维托尼乌斯写道，他会判处他们去矿山劳动，或是去修路，或是被扔给野兽，或是像动物一样四肢着地关在笼子里，或是被锯成两半。所以这些可都没什么好玩的。他对精英阶层的复仇甚至延伸到了推翻他们的祖先。苏维托尼乌斯说，罗马历史名人雕像被推翻并砸成碎片。他还说，拥有著名姓氏的贵族成员被告知要抛弃这些姓氏。比如庞培家族，庞培
the Great, they have this name Magnus, they're told they can't use that anymore. That would be the kind of example. And there's also very kind of pointed sexual humiliations that he inflicts on them. So he will invite senators and their wives to dinner. And while they're kind of lying there, Caligula will appraise the various wives of these senators. You know, if there's one that he particularly feels drawn to, he'll take her away, sleep with her, and then send her back to her husband, all kind of disheveled and is making it very clear what's happened. Caligula will then come back and offer a kind of commentary on her performance. And the wretched husband just kind of lies there looking a bit sick.
大帝，他们有“马格努斯”这个名字，他们被告知不能再用了。这就是那种例子。而且他还对他们施加了非常具有针对性的性羞辱。比如他会邀请元老和他们的妻子共进晚餐。当他们躺在那里的时候，卡igula会评估这些元老的不同妻子。你知道的，如果有他特别看上的一个，他就会把她带走，跟她睡觉，然后把她送回她丈夫身边，衣衫不整，把发生过的事弄得清清楚楚。卡igula随后会回来，对她的表现进行一番点评。而那个可怜的丈夫只能躺在那里，看起来有点恶心。
Uh, and this is where the detail comes in that Caligula sets up a brothel in his own great palace on the Palatine Hill above the forum, and he staffs it with married women and boys, both of whom are of very high status. So I mean, all good stuff. So let's dig into this a little bit. So obviously, because we don't have many other sources, it's pretty hard for us to get a sense of how grounded in reality these accusations are. You make the point, don't you, that Suetonius doesn't present this as a continuous chronological narrative. It's just a sort of bullet pointed list of the
呃，这就是细节所在，卡igula在福论坛上方帕拉蒂尼山上的大宫殿里设立了一家妓院，里面的工作人员都是已婚妇女和男孩，两者的社会地位都非常高。所以，嗯，都是好料。让我们深入探讨一下。显然，由于我们没有多少其他来源，我们很难弄清楚这些指控有多少现实根据。你提出了这样一个观点，不是吗？苏维托尼乌斯并没有把这呈现为一条连续的按时间顺序叙述的叙事线。这只是一份列举了吉拉吉拉
bad things that Gila Gila is supposed to have done. Yeah, that's right. And so it is difficult to kind of to get a sense of it as a narrative. But I think it's just about possible if you map Suetonius's account with the various other fragments of evidence that we have to kind of get a narrative of Caligula's reign. So he comes to power, first eight months, it's kind of okay. There's nothing particularly shocking from the senatorial point of view that's happening, even though there is a sense of menace. Then he falls ill. When he recovers, he eliminates, he eliminates Gamalus, his inconceivable rival, and anyone who he thinks might be a kind of
据称做过的坏事的项目符号清单。是的，确实如此。因此，很难将其作为一个叙事故事来理解。但我认为，如果你把苏维托尼乌斯的记述与我们掌握的其他各种零星证据结合起来，大致还是可以梳理出卡igula统治时期的一个叙事的。他上台了，前八个月，感觉还行。从元老院的角度来看，并没有发生什么特别令人震惊的事情，尽管有一种威胁感。然后他病倒了。当他康复后，他消除了，他消除了加梅利斯，这个他想象中的竞争对手，以及任何他认为可能构成
particular figure of opposition to him. And he continues in the wake of his recovery from that illness to pay lip service to his partnership with the Senate in the way that Augustus had done, in the way that Tiberius had done. But then it seems that two years into his reign, he's finally had enough and there is this most spectacular showdown. And he summons the Senate and addresses them and expresses to them in the most bold, uncompromising way his utter contempt for everything that they represent. He strips away all these hypocrisies that we were talking about earlier. This pretends that the Senate in some way have any autonomy or power, that Rome is a partnership between the Princeps and the Senate. He says this is absolute nonsense,
特定反对他势力的人。在那场疾病康复之后，他继续口头上表示尊重他与元老院的伙伴关系，就像奥古斯都所做的那样，就像提比略所做的那样。但随后似乎在他统治两年后，他终于忍无可忍了，迎来了一场最壮观的摊牌。他召集元老院并向他们发表讲话，以最大胆、最毫不妥协的方式向他们表达了他对他们所代表的一切的彻底蔑视。他剥去了我们之前讨论过的所有这些虚伪面具。这种假装元老院在某种程度上拥有任何自主权或权力，假装罗马是元首与元老院之间的伙伴关系的把戏。他说这绝对是无稽之谈，
it's ludicrous. The idea that Rome is a republic madness. I am a monarch, I have complete authority over you. You are nothing. You are worms. And just for good measure, he then announces that he is reintroducing the treason trials that he had announced were cancelled with such trumpeting two years before. And the Senate are so stunned by this, they don't really know what to say. And Caligula sweeps out and they all just kind of sit there, ashen the face, as Private Eye would put it. And the following day, they all kind of reconvene and they pass a formal vote in which they formally thank Caligula for his sincerity and the intelligence of his comments. They praise him for his piety and they say, such wonderful clemency from Caesar, even though we're worms, we should offer him
荒谬绝伦。认为罗马是共和国的看法简直是疯了。我是君主，我对你们拥有完全的权威。你们什么都不是。你们就是群蠕虫。为了以防万一，他接着宣布，他要重新引入两年前曾大张旗鼓宣布取消的叛国审判。元老院对此震惊得说不出话来，他们实在不知道该说什么。卡igula扬长而去，他们就那样坐在那里，面如死灰，正如《私家侦探》杂志所说的那样。第二天，他们重新聚在一起，通过了一项正式投票，在投票中他们正式感谢卡igula的真诚和言论的智慧。他们赞扬他的虔诚，并说，凯撒拥有如此美妙的仁慈，尽管我们只是蠕虫，但我们应该向他提供
multiple sacrifices as a way of expressing our gratitude for his clemency and his general all-round decency. So it's a massive grovel. Craigie, so my question to you Tom, so I compared him with Ramzan Kadroff in the first half, you could compare with Kim Jong-un in North Korea. Again, hereditary, but not in a monarchy, right? So my question is, what's the power base for doing this? So he hasn't had a command, he doesn't have powerful allies, or hasn't before he became emperor, he didn't have powerful allies in the Roman establishment. How can he possibly do this? Stand up to these very powerful, prestigious, patrician people and boss them around in this way.
多重祭品，以此来表达我们对他的仁慈和全面正派作风的感激之情。所以这是一个巨大的卑躬屈膝。天哪，所以我的问题是，汤姆，我在前半部分把他和拉姆赞·卡德罗夫进行了比较，你也可以把他和朝鲜的金正恩进行比较。同样是世袭的，但不是在君主制中，对吧？所以我的问题是，这样做的权力基础是什么？他没有统帅过军队，他没有强大的盟友，或者在成为皇帝之前，他在罗马当权派中也没有强大的盟友。他怎么可能做到这一点？挺身对抗这些非常强大、声望卓著的贵族，并这样对他们颐指气使。
He has the praetorians. He has lavished bribes on the praetorians. They are the only soldiers in Rome. So as long as he has the praetorians on board, there's nothing really that the Senate can do. He also has a lavished money on the legions because ultimately, one of the other many hypocrisies that Caligula is kind of ripping to shreds is the idea that the role of the princeps is as anything other than a military commander. Right. You know, he is basically, I mean, he's not drawing attention to it deliberately, but he is making manifest that the underpinning of the entire system that Augustus has set
他掌握着近卫军。他向近卫军挥霍了大量的贿赂。他们是罗马唯一的士兵。因此，只要近卫军站在他这边，元老院其实就无可奈何。他还向军团挥霍了大量金钱，因为归根结底，卡igula正在撕碎的众多虚伪面具之一，就是认为元首的角色除了军事统帅之外还有别的什么。对吧。你知道的，他基本上是在——虽然他没有刻意提出来——但他让奥古斯都建立的整个系统，也就是本应是皇帝和元老院之间的伙伴关系，实际上是建立在军团的支持之上的这一事实变得显而易见。这才是真正重要的。因此，卡igula的元老院反对者也意识到了这一点，这并不奇怪。当然，军团的指挥官们本身就是元老院成员。因此，一场针对他的阴谋正在酝酿。而且这并不奇怪，它的焦点不在罗马，而是在莱茵河，整个帝国中军团最集中的地方。它似乎涉及了众多的元老、卡igula的两个姐姐（有趣的是），以及最危险的人物，一个实际上拥有莱茵河军团指挥权的人，他是一位经验丰富的将军，在应对各种政权更迭等方面经验丰富，名叫盖图利库斯（Gaitulicus）。
up, which is supposed to be this partnership between the emperor and the Senate, is actually founded on the support of the legions. That's what matters. And so it's not surprising that senatorial opponents of Caligula recognize this as well. And of course the commanders of the legions are themselves senators. And so there is a conspiracy against him. And it's not surprising that it's focused not in Rome, but on the Rhine, which is where you have the highest concentration of legions in the entire empire. And it seems to have involved numerous senators, two of Caligula's sisters, interestingly, and most dangerously of all, the guy who effectively has the command of the legions on the Rhine, who is a very seasoned general and a very experienced guy at kind of negotiating all
同样的，关于这件事的记录非常混乱，但你大致可以拼凑出卡igula收到了正在发生的事情的警报，并以非常、非常惊人的精力和速度采取了行动，从意大利出发前往莱茵河。这是他作为皇帝第一次离开意大利，突袭并令盖图利库斯猝不及防，后者被捕并被处决。卡igula的姐姐们被流放到监狱岛。所以你在开头读到的关于卡igula对她们说的话，你知道的，我有宝剑，也有岛屿。换句话说，待在岛上别动，否则我会让人用剑把你们砍成肉酱。随后元老院承受了这种绝对的
the various changes in regimes and things, a man called Gaitulicus. And again, the accounts of this are very garbled, but you can kind of piece together that Caligula is alerted to what's happening and he moves with very, very impressive energy and speed, sets off from Italy for the Rhine. It's his first trip outside Italy as emperor, descends and surprises Gaitulicus, who is arrested and executed. Caligula's sisters are sent to prison islands. So that thing you read at the beginning about Caligula saying to them, you know, I have swords as well as islands. So in other words, stay on the island and stay put or else I will have you hacked to death with swords. And the Senate then endures this absolute
恐怖统治。于是卡igula去了德国。正是在这个时候，他组建了更多的军团。正是在这个时候，他在海峡海岸做了一整套关于贝壳的事情，我们在关于罗马不列颠的系列节目中讨论过这件事，我当时坦率地说过，现在也重申，我根本不知道那到底是怎么回事。我的意思是，有那么多的理论，我们根本不知道。我认为，这恰恰说明了关于卡igula的许多传言变得多么混乱。无论如何，他随后从德国回到了高卢，当他在高卢时，他遇到了来自元老院的各种特使，卡igula告诉他们：我不再承认你们的权威。我鄙视你们。我不承认你们在治理帝国方面有任何角色可言。正是在他
reign of terror. So Caligula goes to Germany. This is when he raises more legions. It's when he does that whole thing with the shells on the shore of the channel, which we talked about in our series on Roman Britain, and which I frankly said then, and repeat, I've no idea what's going on with that. I mean, there are so many theories, we don't know. It's an example of, I think, of just how garbled lots of the stories that are told about Caligula becomes. But anyway, he then comes back from Germany in Gaul, and while he's in Gaul, he's met by various emissaries from the Senate, and Caligula tells them, I no longer acknowledge your authority. I despise you. I do not recognise that you have any kind of role to play in the running of the empire. And it's on his
返回罗马之后，苏维托尼乌斯列举的那些我们刚刚经历过的恐怖和暴行似乎就发生了。这是一场奏效的恐怖统治，因为元老院实际上被彻底击溃了。你知道的，他们在他的面前感到无能为力。他们在他的面前卑躬屈膝，只是，你知道的，就像在试图躲避一个霸凌者的视线一样。所以这确实是自奥古斯都开创帝国以来，破天荒第一次。这是有人第一次撕毁了奥古斯都费尽心机建立的东西，也就是合法性和传统的面纱。
return to Rome, it seems that the horrors and the outrages that Suetonius lists, which we just went through, that they seem to have been perpetrated. And it's a reign of terror that works because the Senate is effectively left completely broken. You know, they feel powerless before him. They grovel before him and just, you know, like trying to avoid a bully's eye. So this is the moment really for the first time since, really for the first time since Augustus inaugurated the Empire. It's the first time that somebody has torn away what Augustus had worked so hard to create, which was the veil of legality and tradition.
And somebody has just said, that's all rubbish. This is a pure military dictatorship. I am the dictator and I will humiliate you. I will torture you and I will kill you if you step out of line. And I think that that's why he has the fame that he does. So in recent times, he's become almost the kind of existential hero. Yeah, Albert Camus wrote a play about it. So this kind of this notion that that politics is purely about power and Caligula is perhaps the emperor who most brutally demonstrates that, most brutally recognizes it. But having said that, he does make one terrible mistake. So you, you know, you ask, well,
有人刚刚说，这全都是无稽之谈。这是一个纯粹的军事独裁政权。我是独裁者，我会羞辱你，我会折磨你，如果你敢出格，我就会杀了你。我想这就是他闻名的原因。所以在最近的时期，他几乎变成了一种存在主义英雄。是的，阿尔贝·加缪就此写过一部剧。因此，政治纯粹关乎权力的这种观念，卡利古拉也许是最残酷地展示了这一点、最残酷地认识到这一点的皇帝。话虽如此，他确实犯了一个可怕的错误。所以，你知道的，你问，
what's the basis of his power? The basis of his power is his popularity with praetorians. And so it is foolish of him then that he can't, you know, Caligula does seem to have loved a joke and he can't resist making a joke even about praetorians. And there is one praetorian in particular, a guy called Cassius Kyria, who's actually rather like me. He's huge, gym toned body, enormous rippling muscles, but has a perhaps a slightly effeminate voice, a slightly soft voice. And so Caligula finds the combination of the muscle man and the slightly female sounding voice very amusing. Yes.
他的权力基础是什么？他权力基础的基础是他对近卫军的受欢迎程度。因此，他接下来表现得很愚蠢，你知道的，卡利古拉似乎很喜欢开玩笑，他甚至忍不住连近卫军也要开个玩笑。特别是有一个近卫军，一个叫卡修斯·凯里亚（Cassius Chaerea）的人，其实有点像我。他身材魁梧，肌肉健美，有着巨大的涟漪般的肌肉，但声音或许略带女性化，声音有点柔和。所以卡利古拉发现肌肉男和略带女性声音的结合非常有趣。是的。
And so, Zootanius writes, Caligula would make Priapus or Venus the watchword. And sometimes when the tribune had reason to thank him for something, Caligula would hold out his hand to be kissed, then make an obscene gesture with his fingers. It's obviously very funny for all Caligula's hangers on. You do that with Theo. I do. I do. So the time will come where he will inflict a terrible vengeance because what happens is that Cassicairea and various other Praetorians organise a conspiracy and this is much more fatal. As is proven on the 24th of January AD 41, Caligula is about to
因此，苏维托尼乌斯写道，卡利古拉会以普里阿普斯或维纳斯作为口令。有时，当军团长有理由为此感谢他时，卡利古拉会伸出手让对方亲吻，然后用手指做出一个猥亵的手势。这对于卡利古拉的追随者来说显然非常有趣。你对西奥也会这样做。我会的。我会的。所以，时机终究会到来，他将实施可怕的复仇，因为发生的事情是卡修斯·凯里亚和其他几位近卫军组织了一场阴谋，而这要致命得多。正如公元41年1月24日所证明的那样，卡利古拉正准备
leave for Alexandria. So there's, you know, if you're a conspirator, you need to go to move on. And that day he's staging a games in this great temporary theatre on the Palatine. Caligula seems to be in an absolutely brilliant mood. He hasn't reserved any seats for the senators. So he sits there and enjoys watching them scrabble and try and get the best seat. He finds that very funny. Also finds it very funny when a flamingo is sacrificed and the blood of this flamingo splashes all over one of the senators, you know, blotting his rope. And so, Cliquet has a good laugh about that as well. Lunch comes, he decides he'll go and eat in the privacy of his own palace. So he stands up and heads off towards his own private quarters.
动身前往亚历山大。所以，你知道的，如果你是一个阴谋者，你需要抓紧行动。那天他在帕拉蒂尼山的这座宏伟的临时剧院里举办了一场运动会。卡利古拉看起来心情好极了。他没有为参议员预留任何座位。所以他坐在那里，津津有味地看着他们争抢并试图找到最好的座位。他觉得这非常有趣。当一只火烈鸟被献祭，火烈鸟的血溅到其中一位参议员身上，弄脏了他的长袍时，他也觉得这非常有趣。因此，克利凯对此也开怀大笑。午餐时间到了，他决定去自己宫殿的私密处用餐。于是他站起身，朝着自己的私人寝宫走去。
He's just about to go inside when he's approached by a courtier who tells him that some Greek boys of very noble background have been rehearsing a musical in his honour and so Caligula turns aside to inspect them. And actually I think that's a kind of interesting example of Caligula turns aside to inspect them. And actually I think that's the kind of interesting example of Caligula not as a monster. I mean, that's quite, you know, he's in, he's told these boys have been rehearsing. He, he kind of breaks off from going to lunch to go and hear them because you know, he's clearly recognizes that they will appreciate that. And he's walking down this passageway to go and listen to these Greek boys when he runs into Cassius Kyria and Cassius Kyria asks for the day's password. And as usual, it's an insulting one. So, you know, I'm a massive girl's blouse, something like that. And Cassius Kyria is not amused. He draws his
他正要进去时，一位朝臣走近他，告诉他一些出身非常高贵的希腊男孩一直在为他排练一场音乐剧，于是卡利古拉转身去视察他们。其实我认为这是一个有趣的例子，卡利古拉转身去视察他们。其实我认为这是一个有趣的例子，卡利古拉并非魔鬼。我的意思是，这相当，你知道的，他身处其中，有人告诉他这些男孩一直在排练。他某种程度上中断了去吃午饭的行程，去听他们演奏，因为你知道，他显然认识到他们会对此心存感激。他正沿着这条通道走去听这些希腊男孩的演奏，这时他遇到了卡修斯·凯里亚，卡修斯·凯里亚向他索要当日的口令。像往常一样，这是一个侮辱性的口令。所以，你知道的，我是一个娘娘腔，诸如此类的话。卡修斯·凯里亚对此并不觉得好笑。他拔出
sword and he strikes at Caligula's neck. It misses and hits the shoulder blade. Caligula stumbles, crashes down onto the ground, but he's still very much alive. He's followed by his litter bearers. They have kind of great wooden poles and they come to the rescue of Caligula. Again, a kind of illustration of the way in which he can command a degree of loyalty, but there's no prospect of them being able to defend Caligula because Cassius Carrieri is backed up with Praetorians who have, you know, they have hard steel and Caligula is soon kind of on the ground being slashed to pieces by a kind of hail of swords. He's dead, Cassius Caerea decapitates him. We're told that several of the Praetorians stabbed their swords through Caligula's genitals. So again, this idea of kind of sexual humiliation, which
宝剑，向卡利古拉的脖子砍去。剑偏了，击中了肩胛骨。卡利古拉绊倒了，重重地摔在地上，但他仍然活得好好的。他的抬轿人随后赶到。他们手里拿着那种巨大的木杆，赶来营救卡利古拉。这再次说明了他能够赢得一定程度的忠诚，但他们根本不可能保护卡利古拉，因为卡修斯·凯里亚有近卫军撑腰，他们手里拿着坚硬的钢刀，卡利古拉很快就倒在地上，在如雨般的剑光中被砍得粉碎。他死了，卡修斯·凯里亚将他斩首。我们听说，几名近卫军用剑刺穿了卡利古拉的生殖器。所以，这种性羞辱的想法再次出现，
Caligula had repeatedly practiced and now it's kind of inflicted on him. And there are even rumors that some of them pick up and eat his flesh, which I'm sure is exaggerated. So this is where Josephus comes into his own, the great Judean historian. He has quite a detailed account that seems to draw on quite authoritative sources. And so Caligula perishes as he had lived, kind of shadowed by, by horror, by horrific rumor and by kind of malevolent jokes. And that is the end of him. And so as we approach the end of this episode, it's probably time to just try and kind of go through and work out what
卡利古拉曾多次实践过这种羞辱，现在这种羞辱也降临到了他自己身上。甚至有传言说，他们中的一些人拿起他的肉吃，我确信这被夸大了。这就是伟大的犹太历史学家约瑟夫斯发挥作用的地方。他有一份相当详细的叙述，似乎借鉴了相当权威的来源。因此，卡利古拉在生前和死后一样，都笼罩在恐惧、可怕的传言和恶意的玩笑的阴影之中。这就是他的结局。因此，当我们接近这一集的尾声时，或许是时候试着梳理并弄清楚，
kind of credibility can we put on this? How can we make sense of all these seemingly mad stories that are told about it? So possibility number one, obviously, and this I'm sure is the case for some of the stories, is that they are just not true. That they are either propaganda or they're literary formulae or they are, you know, sort of folk urban myths, rather like there are loads of urban myths about politicians today that people believe, aren't there? I mean, you know, Boris Johnson, David Cameron, you know, Donald Trump, whoever it might be. There are lots of stories that people tell and swap, but we know ourselves that there might be a kind of metaphorical truth to them, but no literal truth. Right, so there is one obvious example of that.
我们能赋予这些内容多少可信度？我们该如何理解所有这些关于他的看似疯狂的故事？所以第一种可能性，显然，我确信这也是其中一些故事的情况，那就是它们根本不是真的。它们要么是宣传，要么是文学程式，要么是，你知道的，某种城市民间传说，就像今天有很多关于政客的城市传说人们深信不疑一样，对吧？我的意思是，你知道的，鲍里斯·约翰逊、大卫·卡梅伦、唐纳德·特朗普，无论可能是谁。人们讲述并交流着许多故事，但我们自己心里清楚，这些故事可能有一种隐喻上的真实，但没有字面上的真实。好吧，有一个很明显的例子。
There's one story that's told about him that we can be, I'd say kind of 99% sure isn't true, and that's the story that he committed incest with his sisters. So he has three sisters, and his favorite is called Drusilla, and he is clearly devoted to her. When he has three sisters and his favourite is called Drusilla and he is clearly devoted to her. When he falls ill, he names her as his heir, which is a striking thing for a woman in a society as patriarchal as Rome to be appointed the heir of a princeps. She then dies and he does genuinely seem to have been kind of crazed with grief and he proclaims her as a god and we know that that happens because we have kind of independent evidence for it. But the idea that he'd been sleeping with her or that he'd been sleeping
关于他有一个流传的故事，我们可以说有99%的把握它不是真的，那就是他与他的姐妹们乱伦的故事。他有三个姐妹，他最疼爱的一个叫德鲁西拉，他显然对她深情有加。当他患病时，他指定她为自己的继承人，对于像罗马这样一个重男轻女的社会里的女性来说，被指定为元首的继承人是一件非同寻常的事。后来她去世了，他看起来确实因悲痛而近乎疯狂，他宣布她为神，我们知道这是事实，因为我们有某种独立的证据支持这一点。但认为他曾与她同房，或者认为他曾与
with his other two sisters, we can be confident that that's not true, I think for two reasons. The first is that the notion that a powerful Claudian, and Caligula is as well as being a Julian, a Claudian, sleeps with his sisters is an absolute stereotype. It's told about Claudian after Claudian after Claudian. So it's an accusation that is just kind of waiting to be served up. I mean, you might still say, well, I mean, that doesn't prove that it didn't happen in this case, but it kind of does. And I'll quote you a German scholar Alois Winteling, who's written brilliantly about Caligula. He points out not only that Suetonius is the first to mention it, but also that there were contemporaries
他的另外两个姐妹同房的想法，我们可以确信这不是真的，我认为有两个原因。首先，一个强大的克劳狄家族成员——而卡利古拉除了是尤利乌斯家族成员外，也是克劳狄家族成员——与他的姐妹同房的观念，是一种绝对的刻板印象。这个故事被用来形容一个又一个克劳狄家族的人。所以这是一个随时准备被抛出来的指控。我的意思是，你可能还是会说，好吧，我的意思是，这并不证明在这种情况下它没有发生，但它某种程度上确实证明了。我引用一位德国学者阿洛伊斯·温特林（Alois Winteling）的话，他写过关于卡利古拉的精彩文章。他指出，不仅苏维托尼乌斯是第一个提到这一点的人，而且当时还有
of Caligula who were familiar with aristocratic circles in Rome and well informed and who heap invective on the emperor. They would hardly have failed to mention such a charge had it been in circulation then. So they would have mentioned it. Yeah, that makes total sense. Suetonius is the first person to mention it, therefore we can be fairly confident that that accusation isn't true. But that explanation doesn't wash with everything that is told about him, because there are substantiating reports that suggest that some at least of these stories are true. So how do we explain them? And another possibility, which again, Suetonius is the
卡利古拉的同时代人，他们熟悉罗马的贵族圈子，消息灵通，并且对这位皇帝破口大骂。如果当时这种指控正在流传的话，他们几乎不可能不提及此事。所以他们本该提及的。是的，这完全说得通。苏维托尼乌斯是第一个提到这一点的人，因此我们可以相当有把握地认为这种指控并非事实。但这种解释并不能完全套用于所有关于他的传说，因为有确凿的报道表明，这些故事中至少有一部分是真实的。那么我们该如何解释它们呢？另一种可能性，同样也是苏维托尼乌斯
first to suggest, is that Caligula was mad. So Suetonius writes, it is my theory, and I have no doubt it is the correct one, very modestly, that his mental infirmity was due to the coexistence within his personality of twin but directly contradictory flaws, extreme self-confidence and abject timidity. But again, if he'd been mad, contemporaries would have pointed it out. They don't. Is there not a claim that when he fell ill? Yes, it's a popular theory. I don't think there's any evidence for that at all. That's purely because of the order of Suetonius' biography, is it? That Suetonius
第一个提出的，是卡利古拉疯了。所以苏维托尼乌斯写道：这是我的理论，我毫不怀疑它是正确的——他非常谦虚地写道——他的精神失常是由他性格中两个并存却又直接矛盾的缺陷造成的，即极度的自信和卑怯的胆小。但话说回来，如果他疯了，同时代的人就会指出来。他们并没有。难道没有一种说法称他生病时……是的，这是一个流行的理论。我认为根本没有任何证据支持这一点。这纯粹是因为苏维托尼乌斯传记的顺序，对吧？苏维托尼乌斯
basically says it's after that. But I suppose it's more likely, isn't it, that he's politically either emboldened or more insecure after he knows people have been flirting with a successor. Right. So that's why Suetonius mentions that he's both extremely self-confident and abjectly timid. I mean, I think that's exactly the kind of example that suggests it. But I mean, that could be true, but it doesn't mean he's mad. And in fact, Caligula seems to have had considerable political acumen. I mean, what he does to the Senate is very, very brutal, but pretty effective. And when there is that military uprising against him, I mean, he, he outsmarts a seasoned military commander. So, you know, he, he may be malevolent, he may be pitiless, he may even be sadistic,
基本上说这是在那之后发生的。但我想，在得知人们一直在与继任者调情之后，他在政治上要么受到鼓舞，要么更加没有安全感，这种可能性更大，不是吗？这就是为什么苏维托尼乌斯提到他既极度自信又极度胆小。我的意思是，我认为这正是那种表明这一点的例子。但我的意思是，这可能是真的，但这并不意味着他疯了。事实上，卡利古拉似乎具有相当高的政治敏锐度。我的意思是，他对参议院做的事情非常非常残酷，但也相当有效。当针对他发生军事起义时，我的意思是，他智胜了一位经验丰富的军事指挥官。所以，你知道的，他可能是恶毒的，他可能是冷酷无情的，他甚至可能是虐待狂，
but I don't think he's mad. Which matches what we know of 20th century dictators. I mean, Hitler, Stalin, and so on. They may have been horrendous, but they're not clinically insane. It's too easy to say they're mad, basically. It lets them off the hook. But I think I don't think you need it as an explanation, because I think it's actually fairly clear where Caligula is coming from. And we've already hinted at it in this episode, which is that Caligula is a populist, or to put it in Latin, a popularis. And, you know, we've talked before, both in this series and in the podcast, more generally, about how politics in Rome is about vibes rather than about policy. It's about
但我认为他没有疯。这与我们所了解的20世纪独裁者相符。我的意思是，希特勒、斯大林等等。他们可能很可怕，但他们并非临床意义上的精神失常。说他们疯了太简单了，基本上是放过了他们。但我不认为你需要它作为解释，因为我认为卡利古拉的动机其实相当清楚。我们已经在这一集中暗示过了，那就是卡利古拉是一个民粹主义者，或者用拉丁语来说，是一个 popularis。而且，你知道的，我们之前在本系列节目中以及更广泛的播客中都讨论过，罗马的政治与其说是关于政策，不如说是关于氛围。它关乎
whether you appeal to the kind of traditional elites or whether you appeal over their heads to to the masses. And you've got to remember that the autocracy established by Augustus has only been in existence for 60 years and the concrete hasn't set. People who are ruling his emperors are trying to work out what policy they should adopt, what role should be, and the people around him are as well. Augustus had embodied the popularist tradition and the more aristocrat traditionalist perspective, Tiberius had been a traditionalist. Caligula, I think partly out of temperament and partly because he correctly recognizes the weakness of the Senate, goes all in with the popularist
你是吸引传统的精英阶层，还是越过他们直接吸引广大民众。你必须记住，奥古斯都建立的专制政权仅仅存在了60年，地基尚未稳固。作为皇帝统治的人们正在摸索他们应该采取什么政策，扮演什么角色，他周围的人也是如此。奥古斯都体现了民粹主义传统和更具贵族传统的视角，提比略则是一个传统主义者。我认为，卡利古拉部分由于性格使然，部分由于他准确地认识到了参议院的软弱，从而全力投入了民粹主义
tradition. So his instinct is to flatter and woo the people, to give them the entertainments that he himself enjoys. Of course, the spectacle of his enjoyment makes him very, very popular with the people, and conversely to turn against the Senate, and rather than to appease senators, to crush them. It's a strategy to which he brings very distinctive qualities. And I think that one of them clearly is a certain relish for cruelty and domination. I think that the sources are just too insistent on that for us to kind of, you know, whitewash it. I think he clearly was, you know, in that sense, a completely terrifying man. A nasty piece of work.
传统。所以他的本能是奉承和争取人民，给他们提供他自己也喜欢的娱乐。当然，他享受奇观的场面使他在民众中非常非常受欢迎，反过来，他转而反对参议院，不是去安抚参议员，而是去粉碎他们。这是一种体现了他非常鲜明特质的策略。我认为其中之一显然是对残忍和统治的某种嗜好。我认为史料对此过于坚持，以至于我们无法为其进行某种“粉饰”。我认为他显然在那种意义上是一个极其可怕的人。一个讨厌的家伙。
A very nasty piece of work. And with a particular focus, I think, on sexual humiliation, again, even if the stories about him sleeping with senators' wives in dinner parties or setting up a brothel on the Palatine are exaggerated, the fact that these stories are told clearly are drawing on authentic memories of the trauma that senators were made to go through. And for reasons again that we've talked in this series, striking at an aristocratic Roman sense of sexual self-respect is absolutely devastating
一个非常讨厌的家伙。并且我认为，他特别关注性羞辱，再次强调，即便关于他在晚宴上与参议员的妻子们同房或者在帕拉蒂尼山建立妓院的故事被夸大了，这些故事的流传显然也借鉴了参议员们被迫经历的创伤的真实记忆。同样出于我们在这个系列中讨论过的原因，打击罗马贵族式的性自尊是绝对具有毁灭性的，
your self-respect is absolutely devastating to their whole sense of status. Caligula correctly identifies that as the way to really kind of break them. And part of this is the assault on a series of conventions and taboos, presumably. So you talked before about him, the stuff with the gods or demanding that he's worshipped as a god, or most obviously, the story that goes right back to when he was on Capri with Tiberius, that he's worshipped as a god, or most obviously the story that goes right back to when he was on Capri with Tiberius, that he dresses as a woman. And this is about him taking the taboos that mean so much to the established senior, you know, blue-blooded people and ripping them up and presumably delighting the mob, as it were, in doing so.
你的自尊对于他们整个地位感来说是绝对具有毁灭性的。卡利古拉准确地认识到这是真正击垮他们的途径。而这其中一部分原因大概是对一系列习俗和禁忌的冲击。所以你之前谈到过他，关于神明的事情，或者要求人们把他当成神一样崇拜，或者最明显的是，那个一直追溯到他在卡普里岛与提比略在一起时的故事，即他把自己打扮成女人。这关乎他将那些对已建立的资深、血统纯正的人群至关重要的禁忌拿来撕毁，并借此让暴民们感到高兴。
There's something almost kind of punk about it. It's so shocking that obviously some of his supporters, some of the people who are prone to support him, just kind of laugh in admiration at how far he has pushed things. Right. And this is a strategy that Nero will adopt as well. And it was a strategy in a kind of much more modulated sense that Julius Caesar had done too. You know, that you shock people and the shock becomes kind of politically charged and Caligula
这其中有一种几乎近乎朋克的感觉。它是如此令人震惊，以至于他的某些支持者，那些倾向于支持他的人，显然只是带着钦佩的笑容嘲笑他把事情推到了多么极端的程度。没错。这也是尼禄以后会采用的一种策略。而且，这在某种程度上与朱利叶斯·恺索采用过的方式非常相似。你知道的，你震惊人们，这种震惊就会变成具有政治色彩的东西，而卡利古拉
obviously revels in experimenting with that, I think. In that sense, Nero and Caligula are remarkably similar, aren't they? Because they're basically part of the same political tradition. They're playing to the same audience and they're kicking against the same taboos and the same class, the senatorial class. Right, and I think also it's the fact that they have the blood of a god in their veins, and so they can cast themselves as being somehow more than mortal. They're doing the kind of things that gods would do or heroes in Greek mythology. This is very overt with Nero, but it's, I think, pretty clearly the same with Caligula. I think he is kind of blazing that as a policy for an emperor
显然很享受对此进行试验，我认为。从这个意义上说，尼禄和卡利古拉非常相似，不是吗？因为他们基本上属于同一政治传统。他们迎合相同的受众，对抗相同的禁忌和相同的阶层，即参议员阶层。没错，我认为这也是因为他们血管里流淌着神的血液，因此他们可以将自己塑造成某种超越凡人的存在。他们做着神明或希腊神话中的英雄会做的事情。这在尼禄身上非常明显，但我认为在卡利古拉身上也同样清晰。我认为他正在为皇帝开辟这样一种政策，
to follow. I mean, you have to basically be a descendant of Augustus to do it, which is why when Nero dies and there are no more descendants of Augustus to rule as emperor, that tradition ends, but both of them are kind of making play with it. And he fuses that sense of essentially behaving like a god, behaving like a kind of, you know, one of a hero from Greek myth with a genius for spectacle and an eye for recognizing how to undercut the privileges and assumptions of the Senate. And the single best example of this, again, a very well-known story, is that he builds this huge three-mile pontoon bridge in the Bay of Naples, or specifically in the Bay of Bayou, and he then parades across it. First time he rides on a horse and then he rides
让他们去效仿。我的意思是，你必须基本上是奥古斯都的后代才能做到这一点，这就是为什么当尼禄去世后，再也没有奥古斯都的后代作为皇帝来统治时，这种传统就结束了，但他们俩都在这方面做文章。他将那种基本上表现得像个神、表现得像希腊神话中的英雄的感觉，与对奇观的天赋以及识别如何削弱参议院特权和假设的眼光融合在了一起。而这方面最好的单一例子，同样是一个广为人知的故事，那就是他在那不勒斯湾，或者具体来说在巴亚湾建造了一座巨大的三英里长的浮桥，然后他在上面游行。第一次他是骑着马，然后他骑着
in this kind of great chariot. And Suetonius offers this not as an example of his monstrosities, but as one of the good things, you know, one of the positives of his reign. And in fact, Suetonius, his grandfather had watched it and had said how amazing it was. And we don't know exactly when he does this, but I think the likeliest date is when he comes back from Germany and Gaul, because I think it's pretty clear that what he's doing is staging a triumph to upstage all triumphs. Because to hold a triumph on the sea, I mean, that's the kind of thing a God does, but also triumphs, there's a set route in Rome that you follow, and it's up to the Senate to license them. And Caligula is saying to
坐在这种华丽的战车上。苏维托尼乌斯记载这件事并不是作为他暴政的例子，而是作为他统治时期的美好事物之一，你知道的，是他统治的积极方面之一。事实上，苏维托尼乌斯说他的祖夫曾观看过并感叹其多么惊人。我们不确定他具体是什么时候这样做的，但我认为最有可能的日期是他从德国和高卢回来的时候，因为我认为很清楚的是，他这样做是在举办一场超越所有凯旋式的凯旋式。因为在海上举行凯旋式，我的意思是，那是神才会做的事，而且凯旋式在罗马有一条固定的路线需要遵循，并且需要由元老院来批准。卡利古拉是在对
the Senate, don't need you. I'm this godlike figure. I can ride over water if I want to. And then the final and most famous thing, making his horse a console. So I know you have a very, actually I've heard you explain before, I think it's a very persuasive explanation of exactly what this is, because effectively this is just a very, very, this is a satirical joke. It's a joke. So this is the last kind of attribute that Caligula brings to his model of kind of targeted terrorism, you might say, which is that he's funny. And people like humor in a domineering political figure. You know, there's kind of contemporary evidence for that, I would say. And Caligula is, you know, we've said all along that there is a kind of vein of dark comedy in Suetonius'
元老院说，我不需要你们。我是这个神一般的人物。如果我想的话，我可以在水面上骑马。然后是最后也是最著名的一件事，让他的马成为执事。所以我知道你有一个非常——事实上我以前听你解释过，我认为这是一个非常令人信服的解释，说明这到底是什么，因为实际上这只是一个非常、非常具有讽刺意味的玩笑。这是一个玩笑。所以这是卡利古拉为他的这种有针对性的恐怖主义模型带来的最后一类属性，你可能会说，那就是他很有趣。人们在一个专横的政治人物身上喜欢幽默，我可以说，这有当代的证据。而且卡利古拉，你知道的，我们一直都说，苏维托尼乌斯的作品中有一种黑色幽默的成分
portrait that I think derives from Caligula himself in large part. Suetonius, I think, doesn't get the point of Caligula's joke about his horse. So it's popularly said that Caligula made his horse a consul. That's not what Suetonius says. Suetonius says that he planned to make Inca Tartus a consul. He also claims that Suetonius loves Incaitatis, which literally means hot spur. So he gives Inquitatis a stable, fashioned out of marble, an ivory manger, purple saddlecloths and collars studded with jewels and he bestowed as well a fully furnished mansion. Now, all of these are basically the markers of senatorial status. It's what senators want and have. And to be a consul is the ultimate dream of any, any ambitious senator. And Caligula by giving in Catartus a palace, and by saying that he can make
这种肖像我认为在很大程度上源于卡利古拉本人。我认为苏维托尼乌斯并没有抓住卡利古拉关于他的马的玩笑的重点。因此人们普遍传说卡利古拉让他的马担任执政官。苏维托尼乌斯并不是这么说的。苏维托尼乌斯说他计划让英卡塔图斯担任执政官。他还声称苏维托尼乌斯喜爱英卡塔图斯，这个名字字面意思是热烈。所以他给英卡塔图斯提供了一个大理石马厩、一个象牙马槽、紫色的马鞍垫和镶有珠宝的项圈，他还赐予了一座设施齐全的豪宅。现在，所有这些基本上都是元老院地位的标志。这是元老们想要的和拥有的。而成为执政官是任何有野心的元老终极的梦想。卡利古拉通过给英卡塔图斯一座宫殿，并且通过说他可以使
him a consul is effectively undermining all the pretensions of the senatorial class. He's saying, you know, I can make my horse a consul or I make you a console. It's very humiliating for the Senate. It's very funny for Caligula. But of course, in the long run, the joke is on him because actually nobody today remembers the joke. It just confirms his reputation as a madman. And it's, you know, the other example of the joke being on Caligula is the fact that Cassius Carrier ends up killing him. And my own suspicion is that I mentioned,
他成为执政官，实际上是在削弱元老阶层所有的虚荣。他在说，你知道的，我可以让我的马成为执政官，或者我可以让你成为执政官。这对元老院来说非常具有羞辱性。对卡利古拉来说非常有趣。但当然，从长远来看，这个笑话最终落在了他自己头上，因为事实上今天没有人记得这个笑话。这只会巩固他作为一个疯子的名声。而且，你知道的，这个笑话最终落到卡利古拉身上的另一个例子是卡西乌斯·凯里亚最终杀了他。我个人的猜测是我提到过，
I went in and talked to the writers of succession, the Murdochs as the Caesars drama. And I talked all about this period of Roman history. And one of the markers is that Nero and Sporus are constantly being name checked. But I think that the character of Roman Roy, I think has quite a lot of Caligula in him. I mean, I don't know, I haven't asked specifically whether it was an influence, but he is called Roman. He's the most Roman character. I mean, it's literally his name and his character is quite Caligula. He's a Caligula who's still waiting in the wings, I think. But for all Caligula's spectacle and his dark humour and his kind of populist touch, I should say, he only lasts four years and he ends up dead in
我曾去和《继承之战》的编剧们谈过，那是关于默多克家族如凯撒般戏剧的故事。我谈了所有关于罗马历史的这一时期。其中一个标志就是尼禄和斯波鲁斯经常被点名。但我认为罗马·罗伊这个角色，我认为身上有很多卡利古拉的影子。我的意思是，我不知道，我没有专门问这是否是一个影响，但他名字叫罗马。他是最具罗马色彩的角色。我的意思是，这字面意义上就是他的名字，而且他的性格相当像卡利古拉。我认为他是一个还在幕后等待的卡利古拉。但尽管卡利古拉有种种奇观、黑幽默和民粹主义作风，我必须说，他只持续了四年，最终死于
this extraordinary set piece, this great narrative set piece. He's been stabbed and stabbed again by Cassius Carrear and his men, abandoned in an alley. And what's going to happen next? You know, are they going to bring back the Republic? Is the Empire going to continue? If so, who on earth could possibly succeed? Is there anybody left from the Imperial family?
这个不同寻常的重头戏中，这个伟大的叙事重头戏。他被卡西乌斯·凯里亚和他的手下一刀又一刀地刺死，被抛弃在一条小巷里。接下来会发生什么？你知道的，他们会恢复共和国吗？帝国会继续吗？如果是这样，到底谁才可能继承？帝国家族里还有人剩下吗？
And Tom, we will be answering that question next time, but of course, there's only one way that people can hear that right now, isn't there? And that's if they're members of the Restless History Club. If they're members of our very own Praetorian Guard they'll be able to hear it and if you're not and you'd like to join up you can go to therestlesshistory.com and hear right away what happens next after the assassination of Caligula, who comes next and what kind of emperor he was. So Tom thank you very much for that and on that bombshell we'll be back next time with the story of the emperor Claudius. Bye bye. Bye bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
汤姆，我们下次会回答这个问题，但当然，人们现在只有一种方式能听到这个，对吧？那就是如果他们是“不安历史俱乐部”的会员。如果他们是我们专属的近卫军成员，他们就能听到，如果你还不是会员并且想加入，你可以访问therestlesshistory.com，立即收听在卡利古拉遇刺之后接下来发生了什么，谁是继任者以及他是一位怎样的皇帝。所以汤姆非常感谢你，在这个重磅炸弹之后，我们下次将带着克劳迪乌斯皇帝的故事回归。再见。再见。目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击剧本中的任何句子来留下评论。